tatsächlich zu verabschieden umstritten
haben sie gesagt Tina Dauser in der Tata
muss man oder kann man auf ein paar
Begriffe gucken die in den letzten Tagen
gefallen sind in diesem Zusammenhang
Blankoscheck heißt es da Blanco Wums
Schattenhaushalt die Regierung will sich
die Hamsterbacken voll machen sagen die
einen auf der anderen Seite wird betont
dass wir eine nationale Notlage haben
dass Schaden vom Land abgewendet werden
soll und dass man vor allem denen helfen
will und muss die möglicherweise die
Abschläge demnächst nicht mehr bezahlen
können für Strom und Gas weil die Preise
einfach so enorm gestiegen sind also es
geht um den sogenannten Abwehrschirm im
Umfang von 200 Milliarden Euro und dafür
wird sondern eben dieses Geld mit neuen
Krediten in den sogenannten
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds fließen
so ist zumindest der Plan und aus diesem
Fond wird es dann wiederum verteilt an
die die es am dringendsten nötig haben
gleich im neuen die abschließende
Beratung dazu Kanzler Mehrheit habe ich
auch schon gesagt und wir schauen ein
bisschen auf diese Diskussion die heute
erstmal vorübergehen zumindest dann
beendet werden wird mit zweien die
mutmaßlich unterschiedlich abstimmen
werden die aber immerhin noch was ihren
Namen angeht eine Alliteration gemeinsam
haben Andreas audresch ist bei uns der
Vorsitzende der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen und Matthias Mittelberg ist bei
uns der Vorsitzende der cdu/cs-fraktion
cducsu-fraktion so ist es richtig und
sauber ausgesprochen und so viel Zeit
muss auch sein Herr
outretsch es geht um die Strom- und
gaspreisbremse der gibt es die Details
dann im November aber der Topf soll
jetzt schon gefüllt werden kann man also
die Vorwürfe erfunden von Matthias
Mittelberg der sagt die Regierung will
sich die Hamster vor Hamsterbacken voll
machen und einen schuldenvorrat anlegen
eigentlich nicht so ganz von der Hand
weisen oder doch und wenn ja wie sie
haben es gesagt es geht genau darum es
geht um die strompreisbremse es geht um
die gaspreisbremse es geht aber um viel
mehr es geht auch um die Frage wie wir
unternehmen Stützen Juniper Stützen
andere Unternehmen stützen die für die
Gasversorgung essentiell sind in
Deutschland würden wir das Geld nicht
auf Weg bringen dann würde in
Deutschland die Gasversorgung
zusammenbrechen dann würde die
Energieversorgung zusammenbrechen das
heißt es geht darum die
Energieversorgung stabil zu halten
Haushalte zu adressieren tatsächlich zu
sagen wir bringen die Preise runter
Wirtschaft zu stabilisieren wir haben im
Hintergrund Familienunternehmen kleine
und mittlere Unternehmen wir haben die
Industrie all die warten darauf dass es
Hilfe gibt deswegen haben wir gesagt ja
wir bringen einen Abwehrschirm von 200
Milliarden Euro auf den Weg und genau
darüber wird heute hier abgestimmt in
der Tat aber der Vorhof ist ja das
erstmal dieser Topf gefüllt wird ohne
das vorher klar ist wir dann
anschließend verteilt wird das Ganze hat
eine in sich stimmige Logik wir haben
gesagt wir nehmen die 200 Milliarden die
wir dafür brauchen und dafür mit haben
wir einen Rahmen und eine gaskommission
eine gaspreiskommission die wir
eingesetzt haben kann genau in diesem
Rahmen jetzt auch arbeiten und kann
sicher sein dass das Geld zur Verfügung
steht und die Vorschläge so ausarbeiten
die wir dann natürlich mit den
Ministerien hier im Bundestag
verabschieden werden sie haben auch
schon gesagt im November werden die
ganzen konkreten Vorschläge auf dem
Tisch liegen wie das dann eingesetzt
wird aber dafür war es ja wichtig einmal
den Rahmen zu setzen und diese
Finanzierung haben wir geklärt das war
vielleicht auch ein Prozess den wir da
in der Ampel hatten bis diese
Finanzierung so stand das haben wir alle
sagen das sind wir alle glücklich
darüber dass wir das jetzt haben und
insofern haben wir jetzt die Grundlage
dafür geschaffen dann auch tatsächlich
in die Umsetzung gehen zu können Andreas
audrescher Mittelberg spricht von einer
stimmigen Logik die Unionsfraktion wird
heute gegen diesen gegen diesen gegen
dieses Vorhaben Stimmen warum wollen Sie
denn Bürgerinnen und Bürger nicht helfen
doch wir wollen den Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern helfen wir sind auch für einen
Schutzschirm und wir haben ja schon sehr
frühzeitig gesagt als die Regierung noch
über eine gasumlage nachdachte die die
Menschen zusätzlich belastet hätte haben
wir schon die gaspreisbremse gefordert
die ihm die Entlastung ist jetzt macht
die Regierung nach einem langen
schwierigen streitprozess im
Wesentlichen jedenfalls die richtigen
Maßnahmen Gaspreis Strompreis Bremse ist
alles okay das Problem ist nur wir
mahnen solides Haushalten an so wie das
jeder normale Mensch eigentlich täte
indem man sich erstmal ausrechnet wie
viel Geld brauche ich wofür brauche ich
es und wann will ich es einsetzen und so
möchten wir es auch finanzieren erstmal
würden wir ganz gerne wissen was will
die Bundesregierung konkret machen es
gibt für die gaspreisbremse kein
Gesetzesvorschlag für die
strompreisbremse gibt es nichts
Konkretes und für die unternehmenshilfen
die ja outretsch richtigerweise
angesprochen hat gibt es keinen
Vorschlag auch keine Berechnung es gibt
keinerlei Kalkulation und jetzt will man
einfach die Bewilligung für einen ich
sage das mal Geldsack von 200 Milliarden
Euro aber auf der anderen Seite
argumentieren sie ja es geht alles nicht
schnell genug jetzt wird erstmal dieser
Topf eingerichtet aus die die Regelungen
dafür werden uns wenn dann später
beschlossen also es muss ja vorangehen
es geht nicht schnell genug mit den
Maßnahmen auf die warten wir ja bis
jetzt heute werden ja keine konkreten
Hilfsmaßnahmen beschlossen die würden
wir ja gerne mit beschließen und da
werden wir auch bereit mit Ihnen
gemeinsam eine Gas oder eine
strompreisbremse hier im Haus zu
beschließen ist gar keine Frage aber
hier geht es darum man will erstmal 200
Milliarden haben ohne dass uns auch nur
ansatzweise gesagt wird oder auch den
Bürgern gesagt wird was braucht man
jetzt wirklich und was will man damit
konkret finanzieren ja oder wenn ich
einmal die Rückfrage stellen darf das
was sie bei sich in der Fraktion nicht
geklärt haben ist die Frage wie wir denn
finanzieren am Ende ich habe mir ihren
Antrag angeschaut das ist ein Feuerwerk
der Widersprüche wir haben auf der einen
Seite von ihnen das ist ja nett die
Aussage dass es gar nicht so falsch ist
was wir tun auf der anderen Seite wollen
sie aber das Geld offensichtlich nicht
im wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfond haben
weil sie sagen sie stimmen hier dagegen
dann sagen Sie das soll über die
regulären Haushalte finanziert werden da
sagen sie aber gleichzeitig dass die
Schuldenbremse von ihnen nicht zu diesem
Zweck aufgehoben werden soll dann sagen
sie wir wollen mit Einsparungen im
Haushalt arbeiten das sind jetzt die 200
Milliarden da würde mich sehr
interessieren wo sie das hernehmen
wollen sie Renten kürzen wollen sie beim
Elterngeld kürzen dass wir in so knapp
zehn Milliarden dann kann man mal die
Diskussionen abschätzen wenn man das
abschaffen würde in Gänze also was ist
denn der Vorschlag der Union ich habe
noch keinen einzigen stimmigen Vorschlag
ihrerseits gesehen das einzige was die
tun ist kritisieren und wenn man in
dieser Art und Weise
Finanzpolitik Haushaltspolitik betreiben
würde dann wäre in kürzester Zeit mit
Blick auf das nächste Jahr das die
Gasversorgung nicht mehr gesichert weil
die Unternehmen nicht abgestützt werden
würden dann hätten wir nicht die
Möglichkeit die haben doch gleich schon
die Mittel zur Verfügung und können das
machen
einmal zu sagen wie sie es machen würden
da steht dem Antrag drin und dann müssen
wir den Antrag auch mal komplett lesen
wir sagen in diesem Jahr ganz klare
Systematik wie das normale Haushälter
machen würden nämlich einen
Nachtragshaushalt das mahnt im übrigen
der Bundesrechnungshof auch so an der
ihr Konzept für verfassungswidrig hält
um es mal klar und deutlich zu sagen der
Bundesrechnungshof nicht irgendeine
Instanz sagt das was sie machen ist
verfassungswidrig und das was sie machen
machen sie auch nur damit Herr Lindner
pseudomäßig sagen kann dass er im
nächsten Jahr die Schuldenbremse einhält
sie würden einen riesen wir machen so
darf ich vielleicht mal gerade ausführen
sie machen jetzt eine Rekordverschuldung
insgesamt 500 Milliarden wollen Sie in
diesem Jahr aufnehmen sie laden sich
wirklich die Taschen voller Geld um dann
in den nächsten beiden Jahren dass Herrn
Lindner das Versprechen erfüllen zu
können was ja im koalitionsvertraut ist
hat er mühsam ausgehandelt dass er dann
sagen kann in den nächsten beiden Jahren
halte ich die Schuldenbremse ein ich
würde tatsächlich machen sie einen
riesen Berg an Schulden ich sag's ihnen
haben keinen Vorschlag das ist das
Problem
Nachtragshaushalt in diesem Jahr und für
das nächste Jahr ganz normale reguläre
haushaltsverhandlung so und wenn sie
dann alle wo nehmen sie das Geld her
willst ihnen gerade sagen sie können
mich noch fünf mal fragen wir müssen
mich erklären lassen
sie müssen alle Programmpunkte
durchgehen dazu gehört auch Einsparung
das müssen sie auch lassen das
Elterngeld dann müssen sie klar sein
Schaffen sagen wir mal was sie
abschaffen wollen sie haben keinen
Vorschlag das wäre beispielsweise damit
die Zahl ihrer Regierung
jetzt machen wir mal wieder schöne Reihe
nach dann haben die Leute sehr viel mehr
davon lassen Herrn Mittelberg ja das
können wir ja gleich auch noch machen
und zwei Stück für Stück und ich passe
auch gut mit auf irgendwie das hier
nichts unter die Räder kommt ich will
aber jetzt haben wir wieder Zeit
vertrödelt irgendwie für Argumente die
wir eigentlich hören wollen wir sagen
bringen Sie Ihre Argumentation noch mal
zu Ende ich will es gerne erklären weil
Herr Auricher zu Recht fragt wie würden
sie es machen ich sag noch mal für
dieses Jahr kann man ganz normal einen
Nachtragshaushalt machen die
Schuldenbremse ist in diesem Jahr
bereits ausgesetzt das heißt sie können
über die notlagenklausel weitere Kredite
bekommen sie müssen nur mal erst ehrlich
ausrechnen was sie überhaupt an Geld
brauchen nicht einfach blind aufnehmen
für das nächste Jahr sagen Sie uns
einfach konkret mit was planen Sie wofür
wollen Sie was ausgeben und dann ich
sage es noch mal wäre es gut wenn sie
auch an das Thema Einsparungen gehen
würden sie müssen uns sagen was haben
sie an Mehreinnahmen sie haben nämlich
horrende Mehreinnahmen 80 90 Milliarden
Euro weil sie natürlich enorm gestiegene
Preise haben und dadurch über die
Mehrwertsteuer Mehreinnahmen haben dann
sage ich noch einen Punkt
eine gewisse Verschuldung ja zu und wenn
sie rückläufige Wirtschaft haben und das
haben sie im nächsten Jahr können Sie
sogar auch ganz regulär innerhalb der
Schuldenbremse Kredite machen wir haben
nicht einen einzigen Antrag im
Haushaltsausschuss gestellt den
irgendeiner Weise in relevanter Höhe das
beantworten würde finanzieren würde was
sie jetzt sagen nicht einen einzigen ich
warte auf diese Anträge Elterngeld
abschaffen Ja oder Nein Rente kürzen ja
oder nein wo wollen sie es her nehmen es
gibt nicht einen Vorschlag ihrer Seite
sie sind völlig Plank das ist ein
Feuerwerk der Widersprüche was sie hier
präsentieren wir haben ganz klares
Konzept wir legen das Geld jetzt so vor
wir sagen wir haben diese 200 Milliarden
damit können wir die Gasversorgung
stabilisieren Unternehmen Stützen
haushaltestützen sind ganz klarer Plan
den wir an der Stelle auch verstanden
wollen sie erwidern ja bei ihnen ist das
einzige Konzept dass sie immer nur
zusätzliches Geld raushauen irgendwelche
anderen Konzepte
Gas nicht stabilisieren Unternehmen
nicht stabilisieren Haushalte nicht
Stabilisierung oder auf der anderen oder
auf der anderen Seite aus dem Haushalt
Elterngeld kürzen Rente kürzlich ich
möchte es einmal verstehen sie haben
gerade einen Bürgergeld beschlossen wo
ihnen der Rechnungshof jetzt vorrechnen
und jetzt spielen sie wieder diejenigen
die gar nichts haben gegen diejenigen
aus die wenig haben ist dass das Konzept
sozialtourismus dieser Populismus den
ihr in dieser Situation in die Situation
gebracht hat das ist auch keine Antwort
wir treten nicht dieser Situation
der in der Lage ist zu arbeiten bei 1,9
Millionen offenen Stellen in diesem Land
verlangen können dass er sich um eine
Arbeit bemüht
wir haben jetzt alle Sanktionen
gestrichen und haben den Leuten sehr
klar signalisiert ihr braucht euch gar
nicht um arbeiten
wenn sie mich permanent unterbrechen ist
das keine vernünftige Diskussion wir
kommen auch ist auch ein ganz anderes
Thema irgendwie werden wir jetzt über
Sanktionen hier reden beispielsweise
beim Bürgergeld ich würde ganz schnell
noch den Punkt aufnehmen den Mittelberg
schon angesprochen hat und das ist die
massive Kritik die man ja wirklich auch
so nennen muss vom Bundesrechnungshof
der sagt der Sondervermögen die
sonderschuld verstärkt die Intransparenz
was die Staats den Staatshaushalt angeht
verstößt gegen den Grundsatz der
Jährlichkeit und er sagt der
Abwehrschirm sollte aus dem
Bundeshaushalt finanziert werden wie wie
Matthias Mittelberg das eben auch schon
gesagt hat was erwidern sie dem
Bundesrechnungshof mit diesem wirklich
doch sehr eindeutigen und sehr klaren
Kritik an dem Vorhaben
dass wir im Haushaltsausschuss einen
maßgabebeschluss gefasst haben der ganz
dezidiert sagt wie es ablaufen soll es
wird sehr viel Transparenz geben das
Geld ist gesperrte Haushaltsausschuss
wird sich jeden weiteren Schritt
vorlegen lassen dann muss das jedes Mal
beschlossen werden das heißt wir haben
diese 200 Milliarden im
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds und in
jedem weiteren Schritt schaffen wir
Transparenz über Beschlüsse hier auch im
Deutschen Bundestag im
Haushaltsausschuss und machen
transparent das was wir tun permanente
Begleitung der Ausgaben so wenn ich das
richtig verstehe müssten sie im Kern mit
einverstanden sein nein müssen wir nicht
wir haben ja das ganz reguläre
Haushaltsverfahren dass wir auch sonst
für den allgemeinen Haushalt haben und
nicht mehr als das fordern wir ein wir
wollen einfach dass diese Mittel im ganz
normalen Verfahren hier bewilligt werden
und dann können wir aber alle Punkte und
in letzter Instanz auch in
notlagenklausel sprechen aber wir würden
ganz gerne jetzt erstmal eine Berechnung
sehen wofür braucht man das Geld wann
braucht man es und wie viel das haben
wir bisher nicht jetzt geht es einfach
nur um einen Geldsack 200 Milliarden den
man dann irgendwann in beim nächsten Mal
ausgeben möchte was spricht gegen
Nachtragshaushalt wir nehmen ja jetzt im
Rahmen von 2022 Geld auf das ist das was
wir tun das Wichtige ist dass wir diese
Mittel diese 200 Milliarden ja natürlich
nicht jetzt in 2022 komplett verwenden
können sondern das muss für 23 auch
relevant gerade der
2400 Milliarden das ist der Abwehrschirm
den wir jetzt aufschnabel wäre wenn wir
jetzt ihre Bremsen in Bewegung setzen
deswegen ist es wichtig versprochen
Bürger dass die Unternehmen wissen die
gaspreisbremse kommt die Strom ja nicht
Bremse kommt die Unterstützung der
Industrie kommt dafür sind 200
Milliarden jetzt klar zugesagt und das
ist das wichtige Signal was die
Unternehmen die Menschen die
Gasversorgung in Deutschland braucht um
sicher ins nächste Jahr zu gehen so
jetzt ist die Zeit um das ist auch ein
Signal das ist auch eine Bremse wenn man
so will irgendwie unter da bin ich mal
gespannt wie das gleich im Plenum
weitergeht wenn er hier schon so viel
Zündstoff drin ist und auch sehr
unterschiedliche Auffassungen vielen
Dank dass Sie heute morgen hier gewesen
sind auch in ermittelberg vielen Dank
sie dürfen jetzt auch tatsächlich in der
Plenarsaal wir schauen meine Damen und
Herren noch mal ein bisschen auf die
Tagesordnung heute da geht es wie gesagt
in der Tat gleich zunächst los mit dem
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfond er hat es
insgesamt fünf Vorlagen um die es hier
geht also zum einen den Gesetzentwurf
der den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds neu
strukturiert neu ausrichtet und dann
auch im Grunde ja erstmal wieder
aktiviert den gibt es ja schon länger
der hat auch in der Corona Zeit schon
geholfen um beispielsweise Unternehmen
zu helfen dann gibt es Anträge aus der
Linksfraktion auch aus der AFD ein
Entschließungsantrag der Unionsfraktion
und dann muss natürlich auch noch die
Schuldenbremse noch mal in Betracht
genommen werden auch dazu gibt es einen
Antrag aus der koalitionsfraktion also
sehr viel Stoff in dieser Debatte die
hier gleich beginnt wir werfen mal einen
vorsichtigen Blick in den Plenarsaal und
schauen wie da drinnen es aussieht ob
beispielsweise die Bundestagspräsident
schon auf ihrem Weg ist ich meine im
Hintergrund den Gong gehört zu haben und
ich sehe auch dass ich das Präsidium in
diesen Minuten führt und das heißt dass
ich reingebe in den Plenarsaal allen
einen schönen
guten die Sitzung ist eröffnet
vor Eintritt in die Tagesordnung möchte
ich sie noch darüber informieren dass
heute auf Verlangen der Fraktion der
cdu/csu als letzter Tagesordnungspunkt
eine Aktuelle Stunde mit dem Titel
bundesstopp für die gigabit-förderung
falsches Signal für schnelles Internet
in allen Regionen aufgerufen wird
ich rufe nun auf die Tagesordnungspunkte
26 a bis 26d zweite und dritte Beratung
des von den Fraktionen SPD Bündnis 90
die Grünen und FDP eingebrachten
Gesetzentwurfs zur Änderung des
stabilisierungsvorgesetzes zur
Reaktivierung und Neuausrichtung des
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds so wie
die Beratung der Beschlussempfehlung des
Haushaltsausschusses zu dem Antrag der
Fraktion der AFD mit dem Titel keine
neue Schattenhaushalte begründen sowie
Beratung des Antrags der Fraktion der
SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP zu
einem Beschluss des Bundestages gemäß
Artikel 115 absatz 2 Satz 6 und 7 des
Grundgesetzes und Beratung des Antrags
der Fraktion Die Linke mit dem Titel
Schuldenbremse für
2023 aussetzen
zur dritten Beratung des Gesetzentwurfs
der Fraktion SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen
FDP liegt ein Entschließungsantrag der
Fraktion der cdu/csu vor über den Antrag
der Fraktionen SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen
und FDP zu einem Beschluss des
Bundestages gemäß Artikel 115 absatz 2
Satz 7 des Grundgesetzes sowie über den
Entschließungsantrag der Fraktion der
cdu/csu werden wir später namentlich
abstimmen
für die Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von
68 Minuten vereinbart
ich eröffne die Aussprache und das Wort
hat zuerst für die FDP-Fraktion Otto
Fricke
der Frau Präsidentin meine lieben
Kolleginnen und Kollegen worum geht es
heute auf den einfachen Weg hin könnte
man sagen es geht um 200 Milliarden das
ist aber eine einfache Antwort denn es
geht um etwas anderes und es geht um
etwas was für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
und für die Unternehmen wichtig ist
nämlich die Einhaltung des Versprechens
dass die Ampelkoalition noch vor dem
Winter dafür sorgt dass ausreichende
Finanzmittel sowohl in der Heizperiode
22 23 als auch in der Heizperiode 23-24
und ausreichende Mittel für Gas und
Strom für Unternehmen und Bürger
vorhanden sein werden dieses Versprechen
was die Koalition gegeben hat löst sie
mit diesem Gesetzentwurf ein
und bevor sich die cdu/csu wieder
aufregt gebe ich noch mal den Hinweis
darauf dass wir mit diesem Gesetz mit
diesen 200 Milliarden die
Voraussetzungen dafür schaffen dass die
Finanzmittel jederzeit zur Verfügung
stehen wir haben eine gaskommission die
uns in sehr kluger Weise gesagt hat ihr
müsst ganz wesentlich zwei Dinge tun ihr
müsst an einer Stelle sofort helfen und
da sage ich auch allen ja das wird bei
Soforthilfen nicht 100% gerecht sein wer
hundertprozentige Gerechtigkeit mein
Versprechen zu können der versucht den
Einzelfall bis zum infinitum zu regeln
und der wird am Ende nicht dafür sorgen
dass dem einzelnen Bürger dem einzelnen
Unternehmer dem berühmten Bäcker
geholfen wird das machen wir dadurch
dass wir im Dezember bereits
entsprechende Zahlungen ermöglichen
zweitens und das ist sehr sehr wichtig
wir zeigen auch auf dass die Mittel dann
auch im Jahre 23 bereits vorhanden sind
und wir jederzeit auf sie zurückgreifen
können und ich möchte hier auch noch mal
in Richtung cdu/csu sagen das ist keine
reine buchhaltungsverschiebung sondern
wie wir ja zum Staunen der cdu/csu im
Haushaltsausschuss feststellen können es
sind tatsächliche Bewegungen wie dafür
sorgen dass die entsprechenden Papiere
auch beim Wirtschaft und
stabilisierungsfond liegen jederzeit
genutzt werden können und meine Damen
und Herren wir sorgen damit dafür dass
wir bei der gaspreisbremse
strompreisbremse den Stützungsmaßnahmen
für die Unternehmen und auch bei
Härtefällen jederzeit die ausreichende
Mittel haben das ist die Verantwortung
dieser Ampelkoalition und die nimmt sie
dann auch wahr und das möchte ich dann
auch deutlich sagen es ist genau wieder
die Trias dieser Koalition die erfüllt
wird wir sorgen auf der einen Seite
neben dieser Regelung mit anderen
Sozialgesetzen dafür dass die
schwächsten unserer Gesellschaft
geschützt werden und nehmen unseren
soziale Verantwortung wahr wir sorgen
gleichzeitig aber auch dafür dass wir
bei der Frage des Anreizes wie viel
gegeben wird ökologisch denken und dafür
sorgen dass die Frage zu sparen auch ein
Teil dieses Systems ist und es nicht
einfach nur ist Hauptsache jeder hat
genug Geld und es wird einfach geheizt
sondern dafür zu sorgen dass
Nachhaltigkeit Teil von Hilfe ist auch
das ist Teil dieser Koalition und
drittens das halte ich für sehr wichtig
Bürger aber noch mehr Unternehmen
bekommen Planungssicherheit und hier
nochmal meine inständige Bitte an die
cdu/csu erinnern Sie sich doch einmal
daran was sie vor einem Monat dieser
Koalition noch gesagt haben ihren wacht
nichts ihr lasst die Bürger im Stich ihr
besorgt kein Geld ihr müsst um Hunderte
von Milliarden haben wo sind die ich
kann Ihnen das ganz genau sagen hier
sind diese 200 Milliarden und sie haben
die Möglichkeit hier an der Stelle dann
auch zuzustimmen meine Damen und Herren
ich gehe auch gerne auf die Kritik des
Rechnungshofes sein
ich glaube ohne den Rechnungshof würde
einen Teil von Jackson balances in
unserer Demokratie fehlen aber dennoch
ist ein Bundesrechnungshof nicht
unfehlbar und das haben wir dann uns ja
auch angehört gestern an der Stelle ja
dass die Linken da besonders klatschen
ist mir auch klar bei der Aussage aber
wir mussten feststellen dass der
Rechnungshof selber sagte dass er die
Frage wie die Finanzierung der 200
Milliarden erfolgt noch gar nicht
geprüft hat er gab sogar zu dass es
sachliche Zusammenhänge über die Jahre
gibt konnte aber an der Stelle dann auch
nicht sagen wie die Lösungen eigentlich
wäre und das möchte ich dann deutlich
sagen ja Haushalte sind in Jährlichkeit
und ich bin sicher im Mittelberg wird
das nachher wieder alles irgendwo
versuchen zu skandalisieren aber ich
will in eines deutlich zum Thema
Jährlichkeit sagen eine Fraktion die
selber viele Sondervermögen mit guten
Gründen den wir als FDP in der Position
auch in Teilen zugestimmt haben immer
wieder Sondervermögen in den Fällen
macht wo sie übrigens von der Verfassung
auch vorgesehen sind die Verfassung
verbietet keine Sondervermögen da ist es
dann auch notwendig zu prüfen machen wir
es mit einem Sondervermögen und das sage
ich deutlich wenn die cdu/csu sagt wir
wollen keine Sondervermögen dann frage
ich mich hätten sie bei den Opfern im
Aartal gesagt ach übrigens ob ihr im
nächsten Jahr noch Geld kriegt das
können wir euch noch nicht sagen das
können wir euch erst im November sagen
wenn wir den Haushalt für das nächste
Jahr beschließen ob ihr bei der
bundeswehrinvestitionen machen könnt das
können wir euch gegen Ende des Jahres
erst sagen wir machen das nicht nein
auch da sie machen einen Sondervermögen
ja ich gestehe zu sie ändern sogar sie
sind sogar bereit für Sondervermögen die
Verfassung zu ändern und dann sage ich
ihnen zu dem und das erwarte ich dann
auch wenn die jetzt von der cdu/csu wenn
Sie hier berechtigt im Namen ihrer
oppositionsaufgabe das kritisiert etwas
zu tun was sie bisher in Haushalt und
finanzdebatten nicht tut nämlich
wirklich ihre alternative durchgerechnet
dazu legen und nicht einfach zu sagen
Alternativen ist nicht unsere Aufgabe
eigentlich zu meinen Alternativen
darlegen können wir eigentlich gar nicht
das ist ihr Problem und da müssen sie
sich dran messen lassen in den nächsten
Minuten hier im Plenum meine Damen und
Herren ich will es deswegen ganz
deutlich sagen viel mehr
Parlamentsrechte ein wir sorgen für
Kontrollen wir sorgen an ganz vielen
Stellen dafür dass dieses Parlament sehr
genau dafür sorgen wird dass nach diesen
200 Milliarden in den nächsten Wochen
die umsetzungsgesetze kommen mit
Parlamentsbeteiligung beteiligen sie
sich dann und bitte machen Sie endlich
mal Vorschläge die konkret
durchgerichtet sind und nicht einfach
nur pure simple Oppositionen dafür ist
die Sache zu ernst herzlichen Dank
Otto Fricke der haushaltspolitische
Sprecher der FDP-Fraktion hat die
Debatte eröffnet die abschließende
Beratung über das
stabilisierungsfondsgesetz und
es geht um nicht mehr und nicht weniger
als die 200 Milliarden Euro die als
Abwehrschirm dienen sollen meine Damen
und Herren um das gleich klarzustellen
wir wollen auch ein Schutzschirm für die
Menschen und für die Betriebe in unserem
Land in dieser Krise um das ganz
klarzustellen das Problem ist aber heute
geht es gar nicht um diesen Schutzschirm
heute geht es auch nicht um
gaspreisbremse strompreisbremse und
unternehmenshilfen da steht hier heute
gar nicht zur Debatte der steht auch
nicht zur Entscheidung heute steht zur
Entscheidung und da widerspreche ich
Ihnen ausdrücklicher Fricke weil sie
haben versucht das genau andersrum
darzustellen heute steht einfach zu
Entscheidung dass Sie von uns ein
Geldsack haben wollen gefüllt mit 200
Milliarden Euro und den wollen sie sich
dann in den Keller ihrer Regierung
stellen und dann wollen sie überlegen
und dann wollen sie überlegen was sie
mit dem Geld anfangen das ist die
Wirklichkeit
das ist die Wahrheit
[Applaus]
ich sage Ihnen ja die Wirklichkeit ist
dass wir kein konkreten Vorschlag haben
für ihre gaspreisbremse wir haben bisher
nur ein Kommissionsvorschlag den
Vorschlag den die Kommission entwickelt
hat den haben wir schon vor anderthalb
Monaten auf unserem Bundesparteitag
beschlossen das ist das Thema für ihre
strompreisbremse liegt nichts Konkretes
vor und für die unternehmenshilfen liegt
nichts Konkretes vor sie verlangen von
uns dass wir Alternativen rechnen sollen
wir würden gerne rechnen aber dann
müssten wir von Ihnen eine
Berechnungsgrundlage kriegen was wollen
Sie denn machen kein Mensch in diesem
Land weiß was sie konkret machen
nein das Gegenteil ist doch richtig wie
sie zu recht sagen die Menschen in
diesem Land sind in größten Sorgen
teilweise in Angst weil sie nicht wissen
ob sie die Abschläge an ihren
Energieversorger bezahlen können die
Betriebe in diesem Land können nicht
planen und können nicht rechnen sie
können keine Investition tätigen keine
Bestellung sie wissen nicht ob Sie einen
Auftrag im nächsten Jahr annehmen können
weil sie nicht wissen mit welchen
Energiepreisen sie ihre Produktion
kalkulieren können Sie wissen gar nicht
ob sie wettbewerbsfähig anbieten können
in dieser Unsicherheit warten die
Menschen auf diese Regierung die heute
im übrigen ja gar nicht anwesend ist
sämtliche mit Minister sind weggelaufen
wir entscheiden heute über 200
Milliarden die sie bewilligt haben
wollen und wir sehen kein vorhandenen
gegen Frau stark wachsen hervorragend
aber keiner der Ressortminister keiner
der irgendwie zuständigen Minister ist
heute da das an sich ist schon ein
Skandal
die Menschen in diesem Land
warten darauf dass diese Regierung
endlich handelt aber sie tut es nicht
sie beschäftigen sich permanent mit sich
selbst und ihren internen Streitereien
den ganzen Sommer über haben sie
verplempert mit internem Streit im Juli
haben sie uns eine gasumlage eine
zusätzliche Belastung der Verbraucher
vorgeschlagen zwei Monate hat Herr
Habeck gebraucht um diesen Fehler zu
korrigieren und ungenügend und das sage
ich ganz deutlich ist ihre
Regierungshandeln auch beim Thema wie
steigern wir das Angebot bei Strom und
Gas ihr fauler Kompromiss zu den
Kernkraftwerken mag über dieses über
diesen Winter hinweg retten im nächsten
Winter hilft er ganz sicher nicht und
die Frau Grimm die Wirtschaftsweise
dieselbe Wirtschaftsweise die den
Vorschlag für die gaspreisbremse
ausgerechnet hat den sie ja so toll
finden hat ihnen auch vorgerechnet dass
wenn Sie die drei Kernkraftwerke weiter
betreiben bis Ende 24 dann würde der
Strompreis um bis zu zwölf Prozent
billiger werden wenn die Menschen in
diesem Land im nächsten Jahr zwölf
Prozent mehr für ihren Strompreis zahlen
dann haben sie das dem Frieden in dieser
Ampel und der Grünen Ideologie zu
verdanken das ist die Wirklichkeit
so
und jetzt sage ich ihnen zu dem Thema
Finanzierung wir würden sie bei ihrem
Schutzschirm wirklich gerne unterstützen
und das ist ehrlich gemeint es geht
nicht darum dass diese Opposition sich
eine Unterstützung verweigert aber ich
sage es nochmal wir würden dann von
ihnen auch wenigstens mal ein konkretes
Konzept für die gaspreisbremse für die
strompreisbremse und eine Berechnung für
die unternehmenshilfen auf den Tisch
stehen die könnten wir dann prüfen damit
können wir uns auseinandersetzen wie
normale Menschen die überlegen doch auch
erst was kaufe ich mir was kostet und
dann gehen sie zur Bank und holen sich
das Geld und sie erklären uns hier ist
wir logisch wenn man es genau umgekehrt
machen würde nein es ist schwachsinn was
sie machen und das ist nicht zu
begründen
sie wissen nicht wofür sie das Geld
brauchen sie wissen nicht wann sie das
Geld brauchen und trotzdem wollen Sie
von uns eine Blanco Zusage über 200
Milliarden das kann man doch gar nicht
das kann man gar nicht gutheißen das ist
unmöglich
ihre Finanzierungsmethode ist maximal
unsolide und das hat ihnen auch der
Bundesrechnungshof in dieser Woche
vorgehalten der ihnen erklärt hat dass
es verfassungsrechtlich ausgesprochen
fragwürdig ist was sie machen sie wollen
jetzt
sie wollen sich jetzt 200 Milliarden
Euro in den Keller legen wollen alle
diese Kredite auf dieses Jahr rechnen
damit dann ihr Finanzminister der ja
versprochen hat dass er die
Schuldenbremse im nächsten Jahr einhält
damit der dann sagen kann weil er jetzt
die Taschen voller Geld hat damit er
dann künstlich sagen kann im nächsten
Jahr ich halte die Schuldenbremse ein
das ist ein schlichtes Umgehungsmanöver
und nichts anderes
ehrlich wäre
ehrlich wäre wenn wir in diesem Jahr
einen Nachtragshaushalt beraten und
verabschieden würden und da werden wir
es völlig okay wenn Sie den jetzt
arbeiten und vorlegen und im nächsten
Jahr machen wir das oder für das nächste
Jahr machen wir es im regulären
Haushaltsverfahren dann sagen Sie wie
viel Geld sie zu welchen Zwecken
brauchen wann sie es brauchen dann sagen
Sie bitte auch an welchen Stellen im
Haushalt Sie einsparen wollen da haben
sie bisher überhaupt nichts auf die
Leiste gebracht obwohl sich in ihrem
eigenen Koalitionsvertrag versprochen
haben dann würden wir gerne eine
Berechnung der Mehreinnahmen sehen die
nämlich wegen der gestiegenen Preise
gewaltig sind am meisten verdient daran
der Finanzminister
dann haben sie Spielraum in der
Schuldenbremse von Verfassung wegen bei
rückläufiger Konjunktur das wissen sie
hoffentlich so und wenn es dann nicht
reicht dann sage ich auch können wir
über die notlagenklausel sprechen woran
uns liegt und das sage ich Ihnen jetzt
ganz deutlich ist dass wir jährlich
präzise abrechnen dass wir die
Verfassung und das Haushaltsrecht
Einhalten von uns werden sie heute keine
pauschalermächtigung kriegens zu 200
Milliarden schlichter Schulden bei denen
wir nicht ansatzweise wissen wofür wann
und wie das Geld ausgegeben werden soll
herzlichen Dank
Matthias Mittelberg ist einer der
stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden der
Unionsfraktion und Sie merken meine
Damen und Herren wenn es ums Geld geht
kochen die Emotionen auch schon mal hoch
Matthias Mittelberg hat unter anderem
kritisiert dass die zuständigen Minister
für Wirtschaft aber auch für Finanzen
nicht da sind in dieser Debatte nun die
können sich nicht zwei Teilen die sind
nämlich im Gespräch um den
regierungschefinnen und Chefs der
Bundesländer in Hannover auch da stehen
wichtige Gespräche an und dass der
Bundeskanzler nicht da ist ist auch
bekannt der ist ja beim Europäischen Rat
in Brüssel Matthias Mörsch der stellt
einer der stellvertretenden Vorsitzende
der SPD-Fraktion ist der nächste Redner
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen lieber Kollege Middelberg man
muss immer überlegen welche Worte wir
man hier wählt wenn sie von Schwachsinn
reden ich wäre sehr vorsichtig an ihrer
Stelle heute diese Begrifflichkeit
tatsächlich zu nehmen wenn Sie
wenn sie verweigern hier heute die
Grundvoraussetzung dass wir die
Bevölkerung und die Unternehmen in
diesem Land schützen können das ist ihr
Handeln heute zu dieser Minute
sie halten ihre Rede daran auf sich zu
beschweren das Minister nicht da sind
ehrlicherweise es ist nicht die Stunde
der Regierung es ist die Stunde des
Parlaments jetzt hier heute die
Grundlagen zu schaffen und das machen
sie nicht
sie werfen der Ampelkoalition vor nicht
zu handeln das was wir hier machen ist
die Ergänzung zu einem 100 Milliarden
Entlastungspaket die wir dreimal schon
vorher in diesem Jahr gemacht haben
jetzt kommt noch ein Paket von 200
Milliarden drauf was Sicherheit in
diesem Land gibt das ist das was wir
hier heute tun liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und wenn sie so tun und wenn sie so tun
als wüssten sie nicht worum es geht dann
frage ich mich wirklich wo sie
eigentlich die letzten Wochen und
Monaten gewesen sind es ist im übrigen
es ist im es ist im übrigen es ist im es
tut weh ich weiß das war wirklich so so
so eine Vorlage entschuldigung aber Sie
sagen sie hätten irgendwas auf ihrem
Parteitag beschlossen was haben wir denn
hier die ganze Zeit gemacht wir haben
gerungen wie wir die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger und wie wir Unternehmen helfen
können und es gibt eine
Expertenkommission die geparkt hat und
diese nun regen sich nicht ganz so auf
sondern hören erstmal zu dann können sie
ja wieder aber es gibt eine
Expertenkommission da war sogar nur ein
Sozialdemokrat beratendes Mitglied das
war keiner hier aus diesem aus diesem
Parlament sondern wir waren beratend
dabei diese Expertenkommission hat
Vorschläge vorgelegt gestern hat der
Bundeskanzler an dieser Stelle gesagt
dass die Bundesregierung die Eckpunkte
dieses Beschlusses
und insofern sind die 200 Milliarden die
wir jetzt machen die Grundbedingungen
dafür dass wir spätestens im März für
alle Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher
eine gaspreisbremse bekommen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
das was wir hier machen ist die
Grundbedingung dafür dass wir ab 1.1 die
Industrie in diesem Land schützen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und das was wir jetzt hier machen ist
die Grundbedingung dass wir bereits im
Dezember an die Haushalte gehen und dort
die energiebremsen einziehen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen darum geht es
aber ich sage Ihnen auch und das ist
dann parlamentarisches beraten und der
Kollege Fricke hat darauf hingewiesen es
gibt parlamentsvorbehalte die wir jetzt
einziehen und insofern werden wir nicht
blind auch hier der Regierung ein Haken
gibt sondern wir haben als SPD-Fraktion
durchaus Punkte die wir im
parlamentarischen Verfahren klären
wollen zum Beispiel die Versorger in der
Kommission haben gesagt dass sie erst ab
März organisatorisch in der Lage sind
die Bremsen zu ziehen wir wollen dass
wir uns die Phase Dezember bis Februar
nochmal genau angucken denn wir wissen
das ist die Hochzeit natürlich das
Heizens und insofern werden wir auch
darüber reden ob es zum Beispiel eine
Rückwirkung geben kann einer Bremse ob
es noch eine weitere Abschlagszahlung
geben kann und ob überhaupt
gerechtfertigt ist dass wenn man weiß
dass das Parlament eine Bremse einzieht
in diesem Monaten überhaupt noch
überhöhte Abschlagszahlungen fordern
kann das sind Dinge die wir noch klären
müssen und dafür sind wir auch hier
aufgerufen
und genauso wird es darum gehen ob wir
und das ist das Problem was immer bei
schnellen Lösungen der Kollege Fricke
hat er angesprochen die das
gerechtigkeitsmomentum ob wir eine
Obergrenze auch bei der
gaspreisbremse einziehen können um die
Ungerechtigkeiten zu verhindern die da
sind wenn ich beispielsweise die
berühmte Villa mit dem Pool
gleichermaßen fordere auch das wollen
wir prüfen im weiteren Verfahren die
Versorger sagen Ihnen fehlen Daten dann
müssen wir gucken wie wir sie in
besorgen das ist ein wichtiges
gerechtigkeitsmomentum
und schließlich geht es auch darum all
die in den Blick zu nehmen die nebengas
mit Pellets oder mit Öl heizen auch das
ist eine Frage die wir hier adressieren
und die wir im parlamentarischen
Verfahren klären deswegen gibt es
weitere Vorschläge von Fonds von
härtefallfonds etc das ist aber die
Grundbedingung überhaupt um einsteigen
zu können dass wir die finanziellen
Mittel haben dieses tatsächlich zu heben
und insofern vielleicht überlegen sich
normal ich glaube sind 60 Minuten das
was sie hier machen ist
verantwortungsvolle verantwortungslose
Oppositionspolitik und insofern bitte
ich Sie wirklich noch mal diese Dinge
tatsächlich zu hinterfragen es ist die
Grundbedingung dafür dass wir diesem
Land helfen vielen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit
nächster Redner für die afd-fraktion
Albrecht Glaser
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
diese Regierung hat das Energiegeschäft
mit Russland eingestellt weil sie das zu
Erreichung außenpolitischer Ziele für
erforderlich sind
wenn die Regierung dies tut dann muss
sie einen Plan haben für die daraus
entstehenden Folgen sie muss wissen dass
Deutschland bisher 46 Prozent der
Ölimporte und 55 Prozent der Gasimporte
aus Russland bezieht sie muss wissen
dass weder die dahinterstehende
Energiemenge noch die erforderliche
Logistik hierfür zeitnah ersetzbar ist
diese Regierung muss auch wissen dass
die Energieträger Mineralien und Gas 60
Prozent der Energie
darstellen die hier im Land verbraucht
wird Strom macht 20 Prozent der
Endenergie aus und die Erneuerbaren 8,8
Prozent aus diesen wenigen jedoch
fundamentalen zusammen ergibt sich dass
die
Energieimporte von Russland knapp ein
Drittel der Energiebasis dieses Landes
ausmachen
die schlagartige Beendigung dieses
energieimports muss also zu einer ebenso
schlagartigen Energiekrise in
Deutschland führen
sie bedeutet exorbitante Preiserhöhung
für alle Abnehmer Versorgungsengpässe
und Versorgungsunterbrechung
der Energie die Lebensader für eine
moderne Volkswirtschaft und eine
zivilisierte Gesellschaft ist handelt es
sich bei dem was wir jetzt erleben um
einen Anschlag auf diesen Staat und der
ist ausgeführt worden von dieser
Regierung
eine Regierung die unablässig den
Begriff der Verantwortung im Mund
geführt muss sie bei einem solchen
extraordinären regierungsversagen auch
tragen
stattdessen legen Sie uns zum zweiten
Mal in diesem Jahr einen Beschluss zu
Durchbrechung der Schuldenbremse vor im
Juni haben Sie zusätzlich 116 Milliarden
verlangt wegen der Pandemie und wegen
des russischen angriffskriegs wie sie
dort schon schreiben heute wollen sie
weitere 200 Milliarden und verweisen
erneut auf dem russischen Angriffskrieg
und die Einstellung der Gaslieferungen
und was die Höhe des Kredits angeht
darauf das ist ein deutliches Zeichen an
Russland sei das möge verstehen wer will
dabei steht überhaupt noch nicht fest
wer wann was bekommen soll und Russland
zeigen sie dass wir mächtig Schulden
machen müssen zur Krisenbewältigung ein
außerordentliches Zeichen der Stärke die
Kreditmittel sollen in einem
ungewidmeten Sondervermögen sofort
aufgenommen dort für 23 und 24 gebunkert
und bis
2058 durch unsere Enkel getilgt werden
das ist alles so nicht geht hat in der
Rechnungshof erklärt mit dem sie aber
gar nicht reden deshalb werden wir den
durchbrechungsbeschluss auch ablehnen
sie behandeln die Schuldenbremse genauso
wie die EU-Staaten den stabilitäts-
Unterstützung von Bürgern und
Unternehmen muss sein aber sie ist keine
Lösung des deutschen Energieproblems und
wird schnell unbezahlbar sie ist nur
vertretbar wenn Sie sofort mit einer
neuen Energiepolitik beginnen auf alle
Fälle einer Energiepolitik bei der die
Kernenergie vorkommt
die empfiehlt übrigens die Kernenergie
auf Kreta wenn Ihnen das weiterhilft
wer Energieversorgung allein auf Wind
und Sonne stützt hat die trivialphysik
nicht verstanden
er produziert damit die nächsten
energiekatastrophen der Rest der Welt
außerhalb Deutschlands weiß dies und
Handel entsprechend wir richten uns im
fern wir richten uns im Traumland ein
und meinen wir kommen um die nächsten
Krisen drumherum wir kündigen Ihnen an
sie werden stattfinden und sie werden
dafür politisch bezahlen
nächster Redner für die Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen dr Sebastian Schäfer
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
Putin und seine Truppen eskalieren ihren
terrorkrieg auch in dieser Woche immer
weiter
Drohnenangriffe bedrohen die
Zivilbevölkerung das ist brutal und
niederträchtig
die Energieversorgung in der Ukraine
wird zunehmend zerstört ganz gezielt
jetzt vor dem Winter das ist der
Hintergrund für unsere Debatte heute
Morgen und das dürfen wir bei unserer
doch stark nach innen gerichteten
Debatte nicht vergessen
die Sorgen um die wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung um unseren Wohlstand treibt
uns alle um in diesem Hohen Haus naja
fast alle manche wünschen sich ja immer
mehr Krise aber es geht doch darum einen
gemeinsamen Weg zu finden wie wir
unseren Wohlstand erhalten und künftig
auf eine tragfähige nachhaltige
Grundlage stellen können das ist
das ist keine nationale Frage das bleibt
eine europäische Aufgabe und da sehen
wir elementare Fortschritte das ist ja
in der Nacht deutlich geworden
da sind weitere Gespräche notwendig die
Energieminister werden das nächste Woche
in Brüssel weiter konkretisieren
entscheidend bleibt das
putinskalkulation nicht aufgeht und die
EU solidarisch und geschlossen bleibt
und ich will daran erinnern dass wir mit
unserer Fixierung auf russisches
pipeline-gas aus einer miserablen
Situation gestartet sind und bei unseren
europäischen Partnern sehr viel
Vertrauen verloren haben
es ist richtig dass wir jetzt mit dem
Abwehrschirm
so entschlossen den wirtschaftlichen
Folgen des russischen antriebskrieges
begegnen wir setzen mit den 200
Milliarden Euro ein klares Zeichen dass
wir der russischen Aggression trotzen
und zwar so lange wie das notwendig ist
es geht um Sicherheit
Vertrauen und Entlastungen in diesem und
im nächsten Winter für unsere
Bürgerinnen und Bürger für unsere
Unternehmen für unsere sozialen
Einrichtungen und als Haushaltspolitiker
sage ich ihnen wir nutzen alle unsere
Kontrollrechte als Parlamentarierinnen
und Parlamentarier wenn es um solche
Summen geht ist das selbstverständlich
wir werden uns engmaschig über den
Abfluss aus dem WSF informieren lassen
ab 1.1 wird der Haushaltsausschuss
monatlich über die programmausgaben
unterrichtet der Erfolg der Maßnahmen
und Programme wird kontrolliert und
evaluiert wir verhindern Mitnahmeeffekte
es wird keine Boni geben in Unternehmen
die Stützungsmaßnahmen erhalten
wir werden in dieser Krise nur gemeinsam
bestehen und bei allem Verständnis für
ihre Kritik mit ihrem kleinen
politischen Karo kommen wir in dieser
Situation nicht weiter herzlichen Dank
Sebastian Schäfer für die Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen in dieser Debatte
über den pardon 200 Milliarden Abwehr
Schirm und in dieser Debatte jetzt
gesehene löt stellvertretende
Vorsitzende der Linksfraktion
morgen werden Menschen in sechs großst
auch hier in Berlin unter dem Motto
solidarischer Herbst auf die Straße
gehen aufgerufen haben unter anderem
Gewerkschaften und Sozialverbände und
wir als LINKE unterstützen diese
Demonstration meine Damen und Herren
und diese Solidarität schießt auch die
Menschen ein die vor dem Krieg Russlands
gegen die Ukraine geflüchtet sind aber
ich sage die Solidarität muss auch für
die Menschen gelten die aus anderen
kriegs-
der Brandanschlag auf die Unterkunft für
geflüchtete Menschen in
Nordwestmecklenburg hat in meiner
Fraktion Trauer und Entsetzen ausgelöst
und darum müssen wir hier im Bundestag
ganz deutlich sagen jeder Politiker und
jede Politikerin ist verpflichtet so zu
sprechen dass daraus keine Stichworte
für solche Verbrechen werden meine Damen
und Herren
meine Damen und Herren eine Frage bleibt
bei dem heutigen Gesetzesentwurf
unbeantwortet wer soll eigentlich die
gigantischen Strom- und Gasrechnungen
bezahlen wir haben eine klare Position
wir sagen die Rechnung müssen die
Krisengewinner bezahlen doch die
Bundesregierung sträubt sich ja mit
Händen und Füßen gegen eine gerechte
Besteuerung von Rüstungsunternehmen und
Stromkonzernen wir brauchen endlich eine
übergewinnsteuer wie sie auch in anderen
europäischen Ländern gibt meine Damen
und Herren
und die große Gefahr besteht doch dass
wir in der Finanzkrise und in der
corona-krise die Kosten wieder auf die
gering und Normalverdiener abgewälzt
werden in den Haushaltsberatungen in
denen wir ja gerade stecken sehen wir ja
schon wo der Rotstift angesetzt wurde
zum Beispiel bei den sprachkitas ein für
mich unfassbarer Vorgang meine Damen und
Herren
der Finanzminister steht auf der
Schuldenbremse und lässt soziale
Einrichtungen am ausgestreckten Abend
verhungern wir sagen Ihnen wir brauchen
einen echten Inflationsausgleich für
Krankenhäuser und Pflegeheime der Fuß
muss dauerhaft von der Schuldenbremse
meine Damen und Herren
und nach allen Vorschlägen die uns sehr
nutzerkenntnis gekommen sind allerdings
noch nicht in Gesetzescharakter ist klar
schon ersichtlich dass es wenn es um die
Verteilung der 200 Milliarden Euro geht
Einkommensmillionäre und vermögene
viermal besser bedient werden als
Menschen mit geringen Einkommen und
Menschen mit geringen Einkommen bekommen
ja auch noch weiter den Auftrag zu
sparen ich werde ihr einfach mal fragen
wenn jemand zum Beispiel in einer
kleinen Wohnung mit Fernwärme versorgt
wird und seine Heizung schon auf Null
gestellt hat der kann sie nicht noch auf
-2 herunter regeln das ist technisch
einfach unmöglich das müssten sich mal
überlegen was wir fordern sind echte
anreizende für vermögende Energie zu
sparen glauben Sie wirklich Herr Merz
lässt jetzt sein Privatjet stehen weil
die Energiepreise steigen nein für
Millionäre und Milliardäre wurden keine
Anreize geschaffen im effektiv Energie
zu sparen aber augenscheinlich wollen
sie erreichen Wählerinnen und Wählern
nicht auf die Füße treten der
Bundesrechnungshof das ist schon erwähnt
worden hat das 200 Milliarden
Sondervermögen scharf kritisiert und
hält es für verfassungswidrig
Sondervermögen schießen ja im Augenblick
wie Pilze aus dem Boden und das
Besondere an diesen Vermögen ist ja dass
die Abgeordneten nur kaum beeinflussen
können wie die Bundesregierung mit dem
Geld umgeht sie wollen uns die Katze im
Sack verkaufen und das können wir nicht
akzeptieren meine Damen und Herren
wir
haben ja die Situation dass immer
weniger Menschen Vertrauen in die
Demokratie haben 39 Prozent der
Ostdeutschen zum Beispiel haben das
Vertrauen verloren und darum denke ich
müssen wir besonders alle Verfahren die
wir beschließen im Demokratie gestalten
und Sondervermögen gehören nicht dazu
meine Damen und Herren wir haben unseren
Antrag vorgelegt die Schuldenbremse auch
für 2023 auszusetzen dann brauchen wir
kein Sondervermögen dann können wir das
ordentlich aus dem Bundeshaushalts
finanzieren wir sind für Vernunft statt
Ideologie schließen sich unserer Meinung
an herzlichen Dank
Gesine Lötsch aus der Linksfraktion
befürchtet eine ungerechte Verteilung
der Hilfsgelder und sie vermisst Anreize
für Reiche und Vermögende Energie zu
sparen in dieser Phase der Krise
Christoph Meyer ist der nächste Redner
einer der stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden
der FDP-Fraktion guten Morgen frau
Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren Herr Mittelberg sie haben
Ehrlichkeit in der Debatte eingefordert
sie haben sich beschwert darüber dass
Christian Linder und Herr Habeck nicht
anwesend sind dabei wissen sie doch ganz
genau dass die beiden heute auf
Einladung der
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz genau zu
den Themen sprechen wozu auch wir hier
sprechen und sie wissen auch dass wir
versucht haben den Termin nach hinten zu
schieben das ist aber an ihren
unionsministerpräsidenten gescheitert
ist sie sind derjenige der in der
Ehrlichkeit bräuchte sie
und meine Damen und Herren
das gilt auch für den Umgang mit der
Kritik vom Rechnungshof die Kritik daran
dass wir Sondervermögen damit
Sondervermögen gegen das Prinzip der
Jährlichkeit im Haushalt verstoßen ist
nicht neu ich frage mich nur warum die
Union in letzten Jahren genau diese
Kritik wenn sie jetzt so relevant ist in
ihren Augen die aufgenommen hat
kommunalinvestitionsförderungsfonds
digitalpakt Schule Ausbau
Ganztagsbetreuung
kinderbetreuungsfinanzierung sie haben
überall die Hand gehoben die Bedenken
haben sie niemals mit vorgetragen beim
Bundeswehr Sondervermögen Anfang dieses
Jahres ebenfalls noch und warum was ist
eigentlich anders ein geheimen Vorbehalt
hatten sie damals ja wohl nicht sie
dokumentieren mit dieser Rede mit ihrer
Positionierung momentan schlicht ein
weiteres Mal dass ich kein Verständnis
von seriöser Oppositionsarbeit haben und
vor allem dass sie in keiner Weise in
keiner Weise bereit sind die mittelbaren
Folgen ihrer gescheiterten sicherheits-
und dann sind wir
beim Sondervermögen des
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds im Jahr
Gang mit Euro aufgeladen
positionsarbeit in den Zeiten der
corona-krise haben ihnen grün und FDP
vorgemacht wir haben nämlich zugestimmt
und haben uns nicht mit dem billigen
Trick hier mit einem
Entschließungsantrag irgendetwas Worten
hinter den Rechnungshof zu verstecken
ohne eigene Antworten zu haben hier in
die Büsche geschlagen und wir haben die
Garantien
die sie damals so groß aufgeblasen haben
gar nicht benötigt sie mussten das jetzt
korrigieren und deswegen sind die 200
Milliarden die wir jetzt in den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds
einstellen an Kredit Ermächtigung nach
unserer Auffassung für die nächsten zwei
Jahre genau richtig dimensioniert und
wenn sie jetzt mehrfach sagen dass sie
nicht wissen wofür das Geld ist der
Zweck ist doch eng der Zweck ist doch
eng umrissen wir reden über die Gas und
die strompreisbremse wir reden über
unternehmenshilfen und wir reden über
die Refinanzierung der KfW das können
Sie alles nachlesen wenn Sie dann die
entsprechenden Unterlagen gelesen hätten
und wir senden mit diesem
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds und mit
dem Abwehrschirm ein Signal der
Entschlossenheit es wurde eben schon
angesprochen für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger für die Unternehmen dass sie sich
auf die Unterstützung des Staates in
dieser Krise verlassen können und das
einzige was ich in dieser Woche geändert
hat ist dass die Union wir haben es eben
bei Herrn Mittelmeer gehört nicht mehr
zu Schuldenbremse steht
und das ist ja das was ich schon
angekündigt hat in den letzten Monaten
es gab immer ein paar Haushaltspolitiker
noch Schuldenbremse gerufen haben die
Fachpolitiker bei ihnen haben bereits
Ausgaben mehr Aufwüchse in den letzten
Haushaltsberatungen und auch jetzt
entsprechend gestellt sie können sich
darauf verlassen dass die Ampel auch im
nächsten Jahr weiter an dem Prinzipien
der Generationengerechtigkeit festhalten
wird dass wir die Schuldenbremse
einhalten werden und dass wir die Kritik
die sie hier äußern mit Lügen strafen
werden dann werden wir nächstes Jahr neu
diskutieren vielleicht entschuldigen
sich dann vielleicht kommen sie dann
auch zur seriösen Oppositionspolitik
zurück ich danke Ihnen
nächster Redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
Christian Haase
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen es herrscht
Verunsicherung in unserem Land in
Familien sind die Thema der
Energiekosten täglich auf dem Tisch bei
jedem Meeting in jedem Unternehmen und
wahrscheinlich bekommen auch sie täglich
Anrufe von besorgten Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern und Unternehmen da ist der
Bäcker aus meinem Wahlkreis der von
einer Verzehnfachung der Gaspreise
berichtet es kommen viele Leute von weit
her sein Brot zu kaufen aber eine
Verdoppelung der Brotpreise will er
seinen Kunden nicht zumuten bereits in
der corona-krise hat er ein Teil seiner
Alterssicherung eingesetzt dass wir da
nicht noch mal tun wenn die Regierung
nicht jetzt handelt schließt er seinen
Betrieb
da ist die Witwe der Vermieter teilt mit
der heizkostenabschlag wird sich
verdreifachen sie weiß nicht wie sie das
von ihrer Witwenrente bezahlen soll sie
spart schon wo sie kann der Garten ist
längst schon zum Ersatz des Supermarktes
geworden da ist der Inhaber eines
Modehauses die Verkaufsräume lernen sich
deutlich spürbar selbst ein
verkaufsoffener Sonntag habe kommt nicht
zum erhofften konsumschub und am Sonntag
so Montag bringen die Leute die Mäntel
wieder zurück weil sie sich einfach
nicht mehr leisten können selbst der
haarwerk-kulli wird zum Ladenhüter und
dabei ist die corona-krise noch gar
nicht überwunden meine Damen und Herren
und deshalb ist es richtig und wichtig
jetzt über strompreisbremsen zu sprechen
jetzt über gaspreisbremsen zu sprechen
und nicht nur die Finanzierung zu machen
sondern endlich zu sagen wie wir den
Menschen und Unternehmen in diesem Land
helfen wollen
und wenn Sie Ihren Abwehrschirm hier so
loben dann sage ich Ihnen dieser Schirm
hat keinen Stock mit ihrem Schirm stehen
die Leute weiterhin im Regen weil sie
den zweiten Teil einfach nicht angehen
wollen es war doch allen klar nach dem
Einfall von Einfall von Putin wird es zu
einer Energiekrise kommen das war allen
klar der Kanzler hat gesagt er wusste
das schon im Herbst aber außer dass er
Nord Stream 2 durchgewunken hat hat er
nicht drauf reagiert er hätte ja was tun
können schon an der Stelle hat er nicht
gemacht was hätte also eine Regierung
getan auf den energieknebel von Putin
Angebotsausweitung wäre es gewesen
biogasdeckel Weg Kohlekraftwerke aus der
Reserve Kernkraftwerke die Laufzeit
verlängern LNG als Ersatz all das hat
die Regierung getan aber zu langsam zu
spät und immer nur halbherzig meine
Damen und Herren das wäre direkt am
Anfang des Krieges notwendig gewesen das
wäre ein Wumms für den Energiemarkt
gewesen dann keine Zirkulation und
diesen doppelwumms vom heute gegeben
und zuletzt konnten wir das ja an dem
inszenierten Schauspiel zur
kernkraftverlängerung sehen da wird
gesagt ja wir haben jetzt endlich was
getan bis zum
15.4.2023 wird die Laufzeit verlängert
heute kriegen wir einen Beschluss
vorgelegt da steht drin die Krise dort
bis Juni 2024 das passt auch nicht
zusammen wenn Sie nicht bereit sind die
Dinge auch mal zu Ende zu denken
wer glaubt dass heute irgendwas
konkretes beschlossen wird er irrt wir
sollen ja ein Geldsack mit Schulden
füllen ohne zu wissen was mit dem Geld
passiert die gaskommission hat geliefert
ihre Regierung Frau Hasselmann liefert
nicht die strompreisbremse so hört man
soll erst im November finalisiert werden
ihre entscheidungsverweigerung
frustriert die Familien und Unternehmen
in diesem Land wenn er mir jetzt sagt
wir gucken uns das erstmal im Januar
Februar an und werden im Frühjahr dann
irgendwann entscheiden ja nenne ich das
soziale Kälte Herr mir ist das ist
soziale Kälte und kein Respekt vor den
Menschen in diesem Land
und es wird Insolvenzen geben es wird
Insolvenzen geben dass hängt jetzt schon
anders können Sie jetzt schon an den
Zahlen lesen und jeder dieser Betriebe
gilt auf ihre Kappe lieber Ampel
und wenn Sie das Gesetz hier allein als
Signal an die Märkte verstehen dann sage
ich ihnen wir arbeiten hier nicht für
Märkte wir arbeiten für die Menschen und
Unternehmen in diesen Land das ist
wichtig
wir brauchen die Entscheidung über die
Bremsen jetzt und wenn sie ihre Redezeit
hier dafür verwenden drei Viertel ihrer
Redezeit verwenden Sie damit uns als
cdu/csu zu beschimpfen als ihre Konzepte
endlich offenzulegen und den Menschen in
diesem Land zu helfen wir kommen gerne
in den nächsten zwei Wochen zu einer
Sondersitzung zusammen wenn sie endlich
liefern kommen wir in den nächsten zwei
Wochen hier zusammen und entscheiden wie
es bei der gaspreisbremse und
strompreisbremse weitergeht wir sagen ja
zu niedrigen Energiepreisen wir sagen
nein zu in der zu ihrer Finanzierung
schalten Sie Ihre Ampel mal auf Grün
danke schön Christian Haase ist
haushaltspolitischer Sprecher der
Unionsfraktion die hier auch ein
Entschließungsantrag eingereicht hat in
die heutige Sitzung und darin fordert
sie unter anderem die Laufzeit der im
Betrieb befindlichen Atomkraftwerke
mindestens bis zum 31 Dezember 24
weiterlaufen zu lassen
Kohlekraftwerke zu nutzen wir
beschleunigten Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien und die volle Auslastung der
LNG Terminals WPS da aus der
SPD-Fraktion
aber es wäre folgerichtig wenn die Union
dann mal eine Oppositionspolitik
betreiben würde die diese Verunsicherung
nicht hochjagst sondern die konstruktiv
Vorschläge einbringen damit wir um die
besten Lösungen bringen können
meine Damen und Herren wir setzen heute
hier den Rahmen den Rahmen dafür dass
wir Gas und wärmepreisbremse für
diejenigen einführen können die am
meisten darunter leiden und zwar mit
Planungssicherheit mit
Planungssicherheit weil wir schon jetzt
Mittel bereitstellen können mit denen
wir Abschlagszahlungen Dezember
finanzieren und aber auch jetzt schon
die Hilfen für den Winter 23 24 planen
können wir setzen den Rahmen für einen
härtefallfonds der dann auch noch
denjenigen helfen kann die noch weitere
Hilfen benötigung benötigen und zwar
Unternehmen aber auch
Forschungseinrichtungen
Bildungseinrichtungen von Kitas bis zur
Hochschule Krankenhäuser alle
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher wir
machen den Rahmen weit in diesem Gesetz
und wir setzen den Rahmen dafür meine
Damen und Herren dass wir mit der
energiepreisbremse auch endlich in den
Markt eingreifen weil das notwendig ist
und damit meine Damen und Herren ist
klar dass wir in dieser Krise auch
weiter so unterwegs sind das gilt you
never walk alone
und vielleicht hilft es der
cdu/csu-fraktion Herr Mittelberg ich
würde mich freuen wenn Sie mir auch
zuhören würden weil sie nämlich wenn sie
von einem Blankoscheck und davon einer
Blanco Herr Heidelberg wenn Sie von
einer Blanco Vorlage sprechen die hier
ausgeteilt wird dann haben sie glaube
ich die Änderungsanträge die vorliegen
entweder nicht gelesen oder es ist ihr
Ziel bewusst die Menschen in die Irre zu
führen denn das was wir heute
beschließen werden sind
zwei Leute sonderbons wir sperren die
aber sofort wieder wir sperren hier weil
heute die Stunde des Parlament ist
Matthias mirtsch hat es gesagt wir
werden erst dann auszahlen wenn die
Bundesregierung uns die konkreten
Gesetzesentwürfe und Vorlagen habt und
dann gilt es darüber aber abzustimmen
Herr Mittelberg ich finde es immer noch
schön wenn Sie mir zuhören würden denn
sie können noch was lernen dass wir erst
dann auszahlen dass wir erst dann
auszahl in die konkreten Maßnahmen
vorlegen wir stärken das Parlament mit
berichtspflichtungen nicht nur an den
Haushaltsausschuss und wir werden auch
als SPD-Fraktion das kann ich versichern
sehr stark abwägen dass wir genau so ab
auszahlen dass es auch sozial ausgewogen
sein wird am Ende
und ganz wichtig und auch da würde ich
mich über die Zustimmung der CDU freuen
wir werden sicherstellen dass bei all
denjenigen die als Unternehmen von
Hilfen des Staates profitieren werden
keine Dividenden und keine Boni
ausgezahlt werden sondern wer durch
Steuergelder profitiert muss an der
Stelle darauf verzichten dass es sozial
gerecht
schauen sich mal die Änderungsanträge an
die wir im Übrigen gestern auch im
vorgestern im Haushaltsausschuss hatten
meine Damen und Herren wir haben die
Kraft
diesem Erpressungsversuch Putins Stand
zu halten wir werden mit diesen 200
Milliarden die sozialen Härten abfedern
wir werden unseren Wirtschaftsstandort
sichern das tun wir als Staat mit
staatlichen Eingriffen und darum zeigt
sich meines Erachtens heute einmal mehr
dass insbesondere in der Krise die mehr
vom der Markt wird es schon Regeln nicht
gilt und darum muss eine der letzten
flörend neben dem akuten
Krisenmanagement dass wir jetzt
betreiben auch sein dass wir klar haben
wir brauchen resilientere Lieferketten
die wir aufbauen müssen wir brauchen
mehr eigene
Produktionskapazitäten hier in
Deutschland zum Beispiel bei der
Medikamentenversorgung um nicht wieder
in eine Abhängigkeit anderer Länder zu
können und wir brauchen den massiven
Aufbau erneuerbaren Energien um zu mehr
Energie Souveränität zu kommen
und darum brauchen wir meine Damen und
Herren ein umfassenderes Verständnis von
Daseinsvorsorge Daseinsvorsorge die nie
wieder so abhängig da von sein kann von
internationalen Marktmechanismen und von
einzelnen und darum zeigt sich auch die
umfassende Daseinsvorsorge die wir
brauchen die gehört in die öffentliche
Hand herzlichen Dank
Wiebke ist da aus der SPD-Fraktion der
Bundestag diskutiert über die Befüllung
des
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds bzw
dessen Neuausrichtung und neu
Aktivierung es geht um die 200
Milliarden Euro die dann aus diesem Topf
fließen sollen um und zu unterstützen
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger aber auch
Unternehmen die von hohen Gas und
Strompreisen betroffen sind Peter
Böhringer haushaltspolitischer Sprecher
der afd-fraktion niemals gerecht
umsetzbaren Gaspreis der gelungen
ausgestaltet werden sollen wer bekommt
Geld welche Preise werden wohl gedeckelt
wie soll das operativ umgesetzt werden
das alles wird erst in Monaten per
Verordnung geregelt das vorliegende
Gesetz ist schlicht nicht
entscheidungsreif
testfrage testfrage an sie alle ob sie
den lächerlich kürzen im Gesetz
enthaltenen Wirtschaftsplan des 200
Milliarden Fonds auch gelesen haben wie
viel Geld sieht er für die angekündigten
dezemberzahlungen vor und ich sag's
Ihnen hier drin stehen genau 0 Euro
gaspreisbremse null strompreisbremse
null weitere Stützungen 0 also Frau ist
da man kann nicht sperren was im
Wirtschaftsplan gar nicht drin steht es
geht einfach nicht da ist nichts zu
sperren wir haben es nicht jedenfalls
nichts für 22
und doch soll der Bundestag nun heute
zustimmen dass 200 Milliarden Euro neue
Schulden in die Rücklage eines
zweckentfremdeten sonst vollkommen
unefinierten schattenhaushaltsgepackt
werden es wäre absurd der Regierung
einen solchen Blankoscheck auszureichen
der einzig richtige Weg für dieses
Gesetz wäre ein Nachtragshaushalt 22
über die nur recht kleine Summe die für
die geplante dezember energiezahlung an
Menschen und Unternehmen tatsächlich
ausgezahlt wird der Finanzminister nicht
anwesend will jedoch mehr als das
20-fache in den 22er Haushalt einstellen
was seine zwölf Monatsbilanz dann auf
glatte 500 Milliarden Euro bringt auch
der Bundesrechnungshof hat genau wie
schon seit Jahren die AFD und
festgestellt der buchungstrickt der
Reservebildung ist hochwahrscheinlich
verfassungswidrig wir sagen er ist
verfassungswidrig
die 200 Milliarden Euro werden 2022
nicht benötigt der einstellen heute in
den WSF dient einzig der Umgehung der
Schuldenbremse die derzeit
glücklicherweise noch ausgesetzt ist
warum geht das überhaupt und hier ist
auch die Union unehrlich an dieser
Stelle weil noch die unionsgeführte
groko 2021 einen weiteren Trick erfunden
hat wonach Kredite schon und nur im Jahr
der Kredit Ermächtigung auf die
Schuldenbremse angerechnet werden die
praktischerweise in corona-zeiten damals
ausgesetzt war und heute immer noch ist
zum Glück liegen diese Tricks nun
endlich in Karlsruhe kehren Sie zum
recht zurück das gilt für alle
unser heute abzustimmender Antrag gibt
Ihnen die Chance auf eine saubere
etatisierung der erforderlichen Gelder
stimmen sie einfach zu dann kann den
Menschen und Unternehmen geholfen werden
die unter der aktuellen falschpolitik
leiden für eine nur symptomatische
Linderung der dümmsten Energiepolitik
der Welt mit Steuergeld sind die
Schadensummen aber viel zu hoch nötig
ist das ursächliche abwenden des
existenziell gefährlichen
energienotstands wir sagen das seit
Monaten und schon vor dem ukrainekrieg
haben wir das gesagt hören Sie endlich
auch beim Energiethema auf die rationale
Stimme der AFD herzlichen Dank
Peter Böhringer ist haushaltspolitischer
Sprecher der
afd-fraktion der Bundestag ich habe
vorhin schon mal gesagt nicht nur über
den Gesetzentwurf
zur Änderung des
stabilisierungsfondsgesetz auch auch das
Thema Schuldenbremse im Grundgesetz wird
hier noch mal abgestimmt Felix Mannert
aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
als Bündnis 90 die Grünen in Opposition
zur unionsgeführten Bundesregierung
standen hat diese Fraktion an jeder
Stelle in den zentralen Fragen der
Bewältigung großer Krisen die Regierung
gestützt das war bei der Finanzkrise so
das war bei der Griechenland Rettung so
und das war bei der Pandemie so warum
haben sie diese Größe nicht warum
haben sie diese Größe nicht Herr März
warum suchen Sie zwanghaft nach
irgendeiner Möglichkeit
abzulehnen was diese Regierung zur
Abfederung der Energiekrise für die
Gesellschaft für die Wirtschaft jetzt
vorhat sie haben monatelang monatelang
sind sie durchs Land gezogen und haben
gesagt bloß keine
gaspreisgasumlage kein Wort zu
Finanzierung jetzt gibt es keine
gasumlage jetzt gibt es eine
gaspreisbremse und eine strompreisbremse
mit einer soliden haushaltsrechtlich
vollkommen akzeptablen Finanzierung und
sie geben hier zu Protokoll und ich
hoffe dass das einfach viele viele
Menschen sehen sie geben mir zu
Protokoll die Unionsfraktion und Herr
Merz wollen nicht dass es jetzt
Planbarkeit für die Unternehmen und für
die Gesellschaft gibt dass sie über
diesen und über den nächsten Winter
kommen
und man muss ja schon man muss ja schon
fragen wie sie das eigentlich mit sich
selbst vereinbaren können sich hier zu
beschweren diese Regierung hätte so viel
Zeit ins Land gehen zu lassen und es
gibt keine Planbarkeit die sollen die
Unternehmen denn jetzt wissen wie es
weitergehen soll und hier wollen Sie
verhindern dass wir bis zum Juni 2024
die finanzielle Grundlage dafür schaffen
dass diese Entlastung stattfindet das
ist doch nicht mit dialektisch das ist
doch schon schizophren
und Herr Middelberg
mich wundert ja nicht dass sie die
Anträge und die Gesetzesvorlagen der
Regierung nicht lesen oder zumindest
nicht ausreichen lesen aber sie haben
anscheinend ihren eigenen
Entschließungsantrag nicht gelesen wenn
sie behaupten das gar nicht klar ist
wofür das Geld ausgegeben werden soll
meine Damen und Herren mit diesem
Wirtschaft Stabilisierungsfonds machen
wir eigentlich viel mehr als im Namen
steckt das heißt
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds aber
eigentlich ist es ein Fonds zur
Stabilisierung der Gesellschaft der
freien und der demokratischen der
resilienten und widerstandsfähigen
Gesellschaft gegen Wladimir Putin und
gegen seine hilfershelfer hier in
Deutschland das ist das was wir zu
Debatte steht
die gaspreiskommission hat vor nicht
allzu langer Zeit einen guten Vorschlag
vorgelegt der jetzt in der Regierung und
im Parlament diskutiert wird um
umzusetzen was jetzt notwendig ist mit
der gaspreisbremse dafür zu sorgen dass
sie Spitzen abgefedert werden mit der
strompreisbremse dafür zu sorgen dass
auch an den strompreisende reale
Entlassung passiert natürlich zum einen
das Schreiben sie auch ihr
mitlassungsantrag
Entschließungsantrag zum einen natürlich
darüber dass übergewinne abgeschöpft und
der Allgemeinheit zurückgeführt werden
aber Sie müssen doch mal anerkennen dass
es Härtefälle gibt die darüber nicht
abgedeckt werden können das betrifft
einzelne Unternehmen das betrifft aber
auch soziale Einrichtungen das betrifft
die Krankenhäusern viele viele mehr mit
denen wir uns doch auch beschäftigen
müssen und deswegen werden wir uns auch
von ihrer
obstruktionspolitik nicht beirren lassen
Herr merkt sie haben gerade bei den 16
Jahren direkt aufgescheucht
sie beschweren sich hier immer dass wir
Ihnen 16 Jahre schlechte
Regierungspolitik vorhalten ich muss
sagen die letzten 16 Monate
Oppositionspolitik für ihn nicht besser
das hat mich nicht mehr überzeugt
sie sagen immer nur was nicht geht sagen
immer nur was nicht geht warum man
irgendetwas nicht tun dürfe ich finde es
gut dass sie das so deutlich den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern transparent
machen ein letztes meine Damen und
Herren mit dem was wir jetzt tun ist
natürlich die Arbeit noch nicht getan
all das muss jetzt noch im Gesetz
gegossen werden und wir müssen darüber
hinaus eine dritte Aufgabe eine dritte
Aufgabe sehr ernst nehmen wir
stabilisieren die Wirtschaft gegen die
Rezession wir stabilisieren die
Gesellschaft gegen diese Angriffe und
jetzt müssen wir auch noch unsere
Energieversorgung noch weiter
stabilisieren mit mehr Effizienz mit
mehr Einsparung und damit werden wir in
den nächsten Monaten noch einige Zeit
verbringen vielleicht wenn sie dann ein
bisschen konstruktiver noch vielen Dank
Felix bannaschak Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen in der Debatte über den 200
Milliarden Euro Rettungsschirm eine
muntere Debatte wenn man es positiv
formuliert in
Teilen allerdings und das ganze
fraktionsübergreifend gelegentlich auch
recht polemisch Dennis Rohde ist ampult
haushaltspolitischer Sprecher der
SPD-Fraktion
der Debatte bis hierher gefolgt ist muss
man glaube ich am 1 am Anfang noch mal
feststellen wir haben dieses Paket nicht
gewollt es war nicht Bestandteil der
Koalitionsverhandlungen wir haben
darüber nicht zu der Zeitpunkt der
Bildung dieser Koalition diskutiert dass
wir heute über 200 Milliarden Euro
diskutieren hat sich niemand ausgesucht
das ist allein Ergebnis des
Angriffskrieges von Vladimir Putin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die reagieren
und wir reagieren auf unterschiedlichste
Art und Weise und die eine ist dass wir
in einem wirklichen Rekordtempo die
Infrastruktur für erneuerbare Energien
für LNG für später nachhaltigen
wasserstoffausbau noch nie wurden
Infrastrukturprojekte in Deutschland so
schnell vorangebracht und das ist etwas
was wir immer wieder betonen sollten
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
aber zur Wahrheit gehört neue Märkte
erschließen neue Kapazitäten ausbauen
das wird nicht von heute auf morgen
gehen das wird trotzdem Zeit brauchen
auch wenn wir optimistisch sind dass die
ersten lng-schiffe dieses Jahr noch
anlanden aber wir wollen diese Zeit die
wir brauchen um Angebot und Nachteile
wieder in den Einklang zu bringen nicht
wir wollen nicht in dieser Zeit die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger alleine lassen
sondern wir wollen sie spürbar entlasten
wir wollen dass Sie durch die nächsten
Winter kommen liebe Kollegen und deshalb
diskutieren wir heute über 200
Milliarden und
das dann die Union von
parteitagsbeschlüssen spricht und das
ist doch konkrete Vorschläge gebe ich
wäre als europäischer konservativer in
diesen Tagen sehr vorsichtig mit
Schnellschüssen das kann kräftig nach
hinten losgehen ich finde wir brauchen
nicht den erstbesten sondern den besten
Vorschlag liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und genau deswegen genau deswegen ist es
doch richtig dass das passiert was
Matthias Mirsch gesagt hat nämlich dass
man diejenigen die wirklich Erfahrung in
den Bereichen hat in einer
Expertenkommission dazu zusammengeholt
hat das Politik dabei ist aber dass
diejenigen diskutieren wie schaffen wir
es Entlastung in diesem Land
sicherzustellen aber eben weil da auch
Expertinnen und Experten diskutieren
Politik zwar dabei ist aber am Ende dann
in die Umsetzung erst kommt ist es doch
auch richtig dass dieses Parlament heute
quasi als sein Hoheitsrecht sagt was das
Ganze kosten soll und kosten darf das
was wir heute beschließen nämlich den
Rahmen von 200 Milliarden festzulegen
das ist gelebtes Königsrecht dass das
Haushaltsrecht liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und jetzt ist damit eben der Gegenteil
das Gegenteil eines Blankoschecks und
ich will es noch deutlicher machen wir
beschließen heute die Summe und ja die
konkreten Maßnahmen werden erst in den
nächsten Wochen auf uns zukommen aber
wir stellen sicher dass mit jeder
Maßnahme ganz egal über den gesetzlichen
oder den verordnungsgeben jede Maßnahme
die Geld kostet muss wieder durch den
Deutschen Bundestag wir behalten das
Heft des Handelns in der Hand und ich
finde das ist auch wichtig liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und ich habe in der Debatte ja gerade
immer wieder diesen Vorwurf gehört das
sei alles so intransparent da werden
Säcke gefüllt und in Keller gebracht das
ist wirklich sehr intransparent es ist
so intransparent dass jeder hier im Haus
mitbekommen hat es geht um 200
Milliarden Euro liebe Kolleginnen das
ist das erste das zweite es ist so in
transparent dass der Wirtschaftsplan die
konkrete Verausgabung am Ende auch
wieder im Haushaltsausschuss diskutiert
und beschlossen werden muss es ist so
intransparent dass jeder Bürger sehen
kann nachher im wirtschaftsbahn wie viel
ist denn von den 200 Milliarden
abgeflossen wie viel ist noch drin wofür
wurde es ausgegeben ich finde das was
wir hier machen ist das Gegenteil von
Intransparenz wir verstecken es nicht in
einigen Einzelplänen hier mal eine
Maßnahme da mal eine Maßnahme sondern
wir bündeln und stellen gebündelt da das
ist maximale Transparenz und es ist das
Gegenteil von Intransparenz liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und es geht ja auch gar nicht bei dem
Vorwurf um die Sache ich stelle mir mal
vor wir hätten das gemacht was Christian
Hase hier gefordert hätte wir würden das
in die nächsten Haushaltsverhandlungen
mit einbringen wir würden gucken was wir
konkret dann etatisieren wenn wir das
machen würden dann würden sie uns davor
würden sie uns doch vorwerfen wir würden
für keine Planungssicherheit sorgen wir
würden nur Monat für Monat gucken und
wir werden uns der größte dieser Krise
nicht bewusst ihm geht es doch nicht um
Kritik ihm geht es plumps dagegen sein
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und das ist der Unterschied und Felix
banatak hat das gerade gesagt und ich
will das weil wir immer in diesen
Konstellation mit in
Regierungsverantwortung hier auch noch
mal sagen das ist der Unterschied
unserer heutigen Koalitionspartner zu
unserem vorherigen Koalitionspartner als
der WSF eingeführt wurde war auch noch
nicht klar wie teuer das ganze wird war
auch noch nicht klar für was genau am
Ende verausgabt wird als der WSF
eingeführt wurde haben wir über 600
Milliarden Euro diskutiert und grün und
FDP haben aufgrund ihrer
staatspolitischen Verantwortung
zugestimmt und haben nicht dieses
Kasperletheater aufgeführt liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ich komme zum Schluss frau Präsidentin
der Rahmen den wir heute setzen erst
richtig und er ist angemessen wir als
Deutscher Bundestag behalten das Heft
des Handelns in der Hand von daher
glaube ich kann jeder Parlamentarier
heute mit guten Gewissen zustimmen
vielen Dank
Dennis Rohde haushaltspolitische
Sprecher der SPD-Fraktion nennt das
Auftreten der Unionsfraktion in dieser
Debatte ein Kasperletheater und er hat
zwischenzeitlich wiederholt WSF gesagt
das wissen sie natürlich was er damit
meint nämlich den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds von ich
sag's zu Sicherheit einfach noch mal
dazu Florian Ostner aus der CSU
Landesgruppe Istan
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wäre die Bundesregierung eine
Privatperson so hätte er inzwischen jede
vernünftige Bank das Konto gesperrt oder
alle Kreditkarten eingezogen kaum ist
das Limit erschöpft wird die nächste
Karte ausgereizt die Finanzpolitik der
Ampel entpuppt sich immer mehr zu einem
gefährlichen Schneeballsystem und für
jedes neue Problem wird ein neuer
Sondervermögen ein deklarierter
schuldentopf aufgemacht und mit Verlaub
bemerkt an meine Vorredner Herr
banatschak von den Grünen als es hat
wirklich nichts mit Größe zu tun
wirklich nichts mit Größe zu tun wenn
man hier Blankoschecks und schuldentöpfe
aufmacht und von Denis Rode habe ich
gelernt das ist zum Königsrecht gehört
Schulden zu machen und Blankoschecks
auszustellen also dies ist nicht die
dies die Problemlösung aller Ampel
jedoch nicht die Problemlösung wie wir
sie als CD und CSU vertreten hat
wir wir kämpfen wir kämpfen also Union
nur die Ruhe nur die Ruhe im Gegensatz
zu ihnen komme ich noch zu den Inhalten
was man machen kann wir kämpfen also
Union für eine Entlastung der Bürger und
Unternehmer jedoch ist es für uns nicht
nachvollziehbar und alle die Ampel
Vorräte haben das bestätigt nach welcher
Berechnung diese 200 Milliarden sich
zusammensetzen auch bleibt völlig offen
wie neben der Gas nun die
strompreisbremse ist schlussendlich
gestaltet ist und wie Öl und Pellets die
komplett vergessen wurden wie hier
geholfen wird der komplette ländliche
Raum wird meiner Ansicht nach
vergessener die Ampel hat zuerst ein
Preisschild erstellt ohne zu wissen wie
das fertige Produkt am Ende aussehen
soll als Union hätten wir eine
vernünftige Reihenfolge gewählt erst die
konkreten Maßnahmen benannt dann erklärt
wie das zu finanzieren ist das wäre die
richtige Vorgehensweise und kein
derartiger Blankoscheck
jetzt jetzt lieber Otto Fricke werden
wir konkret mit unserem
Entschließungsantrag bieten wir konkrete
konkrete Lösungsvorschläge an wie man
den hohen Energiepreisen begegnen kann
erstens es gehören wirklich alle
Optionen alle Optionen der
Energieerzeugung in unserem Land auf den
Tisch nur wenn wir es Pappen die
Energieknappheit in den Griff zu
bekommen werden die Energiepreise auch
wieder sinken deshalb müssen wir alle
drei noch im Betrieb befindlichen
Kernkraftwerke begrenzt bis 2024
weiterlaufen lassen damit würden alle
Stromkunden durch niedrige Preise
entlastet das sogenannte Machtwort von
Scholz ist deshalb schier
unverantwortlich hier gehen rot-grüne
Partei Ideologien vor die Interessen
unseres Landes
Deutschland
Deutschland hat heute bereits ein
massiven Wettbewerbsnachteil aufgrund
der höchsten aufgrund der höchsten
Strompreise weltweit jetzt in dieser
energiemangelage bin ich nur weniger
Monate zusätzlich Produzenten aus dem
Markt zu nehmen macht uns noch
abhängiger und treibt die Preisspirale
zusätzlich nach oben wir müssen deshalb
alles daran legen unsere Spitzenposition
bei grundlastfähigen erneuerbaren
Energien weiter auszubauen schon heute
ist beispielsweise der Anteil in Bayern
Liebe grüne in Bayern mit 52 Prozent aus
Wind Wasser Sonne und Biomasse fast
doppelt so hoch wie im
Bundesdurchschnitt das ist der wahre
Erfolgsgeschichte
zweitens
zweitens wir müssen verzichtbare
Projekte einspannen Blick in den
Haushalt 2023 zeigt ist gäbe
Einsparmöglichkeiten zu haben Beispiele
der bundfinanziert weit den Projekte die
eigentlich Länder Angelegenheit sind wie
Nachfolge 9 Euro Tickets das Kanzleramt
wird für die enorme Summe von 77
7 und das Bürgergeld wird eingeführt mit
sage und schreibe Mehrkosten von 4,8
Milliarden Euro die Arbeit verteuert und
nicht zu noch attraktiver macht obwohl
jede helfende Hand in unserem Land
gebraucht wird das braucht in dieser
Krisenzeit wirklich keiner also weg
damit
Liebe Ampel verzichten Sie auf alle die
ihn lieb gewordenen und jetzt wieder
bestätigten haushaltstricks mit unserer
Kritik stehen wir übrigens nicht allein
da sondern haben hier den
Bundesrechnungshof fest an unserer Seite
der kommt in seinem Bericht zu einem
vernichteten fazit Die etatisierung der
Mittel in den Sondervermögen verstärkt
die bereits bestehende Intransparenz des
Bundeshaushalts ich möchte zu einem
Beispiel festmachen würden wir alle
Ausgaben im Sondervermögen im nächsten
Jahr mit dem regulären Kernhaushalt 2023
summieren wären wir nicht bei den
veranschlagten 445 Milliarden Euro
sondern bei sage und schreibe
613 Milliarden Euro also 38 Prozent
höher als ausgewiesen das hat wirklich
überhaupt nichts mit Transparenz zu tun
der vorgesehene und am Ende wird
entscheidend sein die Kreditaufnahme
hervorrat verstehst verstößt auch gegen
den verfassungsgemäßen Grundsatz der
Jährlichkeit wir hatten es heute schon
mehrfach angesprochen der vorgesehene
notlagenbeschluss frau Präsidentin des
Deutschen Bundestages braucht den
Artikel 115 zwei Grundgesetz zwingend
den erforderlichen zeitlichen
Veranlassungszusammenhang das heißt die
Mittel dürfen nur in unmittelbaren
Zusammenhang der Energiekrise stehen und
für nichts anderes verwendet werden wir
lassen uns da überraschen Liebe Ampel
mit so einer Finanz- und
Haushaltspolitik ist wahrhaft kein Staat
zu machen ich rate Ihnen stimmen Sie
unsere Entschließungsantrag zu und
sorgen Sie gemeinsam für und mit uns für
eine ehrliche Entlastung bei den
Energiepreisen ohne Rekordschulden und
ohne Schattenhaushalten herzlichst
Vergelt's Gott fürs zu hören
Florian usner unüberhörbar CSU
Landesgruppe ich meine jetzt nur die
Aussprache Michael Kellner ist ja nicht
so Redner parlamentarischer
Staatssekretär beim
Bundeswirtschaftsminister
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren wir entscheiden heute
als Parlament ob wir mit den 200
Milliarden Euro schweren Abwehrschirm
die Substanz und die zukunftskraft
unserer Volkswirtschaft absichern wir
entscheiden uns mit dem
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds auch
darüber dass wir nicht nur einzeln
Branchen helfen sondern allen
Unternehmen wir zeigen ja
Handlungsfähigkeit in den Zeiten der
Krise und wenn ich hier die Debatte
zusammenfasse und höre was die Union
vorschlägt dann muss ich sagen sie
stehen auf verhaltensstache die Ampel
handelt die Union hampelt
mit dem
wirtschaftsorganisierungsfonds
finanzieren wir die Strom- und
gaspreisbremse und orientieren uns dabei
an dem Vorschlag der
expertinnenkommission Gas und Wärme das
machen wir übrigens auch bei der
strompreisbremse mit der gaspreisbremse
entlasten wir alle Unternehmen und
privaten Haushalte und schaffen damit
Planungssicherheit ich finde den
Vorschlag der gaskommission richtig in
einem ersten Schritt zu entlasten indem
wir über die Versorger gehen das hilft
schnell wir schlagen damit eine
finanzielle Brücke bis zur regulären
Einführung der gaspreisbremse im
kommenden Jahr die Kommission die
gaspreiskommission schlägt in einer
zweiten Stufe vor die Preise für
industrielle Verbraucher bei 7 Cent ohne
Abgaben für Gas zu deckeln für andere
Unternehmen und privaten Haushalte
schlägt sie ein Bruttopreis von 12 Cent
vor das klingt teurer kommt aber auf
dasselbe hinaus für die Unternehmen für
die Industrieunternehmen und für die
Gewerbe- und privaten Haushalte es
werden damit Grund Tangente für größere
Teil übernommen aber es wird nicht alles
übernommen wir brauchen Preise als
steuerungs- und spar-
starteten wir bereits mit einer
Energiekosten dämpfungsprogramm für
Energie und handelsintensive Unternehmen
mit dem jetzigen Abwehrschirm von 200
Milliarden Euro können wir diese
Engführung überwinden und alle
Unternehmen unterstützen mit dem
Energiekosten dämpfungsprogramm und das
ursprünglich geplante kmu-programm gehen
in diese Maßnahmen auf denn es geht
nicht darum weiter zu diskutieren welche
Branchen besonders unterstützt werden
müssen und welche nicht sondern
maßgeblich darum allen Unternehmen zu
helfen und zwar so schnell und so
unbürokratisch wie möglich auch das
haben wir aus den corona-hilfen gelernt
wir wollen nachdem wir heute den WSS
beschließen im November den Bundestag
erreichen so dass wir unter Hochdruck in
diesem Jahr die Gas- und
strompreisbremsen noch einführen und
Planungssicherheit für die Unternehmen
gewährleisten aktuell sind wir in der
Feinabstimmung mit der EU-Kommission
weil die Bremsen dem europäischen
Beihilferecht genügen und mindestens bis
Ende 2023 gelten müssen denn das will
ich noch mal ganz deutlich sagen wenn
sich die Speicher nach diesem Winter
lernen müssen wir diese mit alternativen
Gasquellen schnell wieder füllen gerade
deswegen ist das Sparen so wichtig und
wir müssen an die Ursache der Krise ran
an die Abhängigkeit von fossiler Energie
wir dürfen uns keine zwei Jahre Pause
als Volkswirtschaft leisten die
dekarbonisierung auch als
Wettbewerbsvorteil unsere Wirtschaft
muss weitergehen dafür brauchen die
Unternehmen Planungssicherheit bei den
Betriebskosten und eine Unterstützung
bei den Investitionen in der
Transformation das ist entscheidend dass
wir diese nächsten zwei Jahre auch dafür
weiter nutzen
zum Schluss sage ich nochmal in aller
Deutlichkeit bei der auswert das Paket
ist werden wir sehr darauf achten dass
der Mittelstand nicht schlechter
behandelt wird als die Industrie das ist
mein Ziel ich danke daher für die
Unterstützung dieses wichtigen Vorhabens
Michael Kellner ist parlamentarischer
Staatssekretär beim Bundesminister für
Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz und er bei
der vorletzte Redner in dieser Debatte
im Volk jetzt nur noch in
Anführungszeichen Kevin Kühnert da ja
spd-generalsekretär ist aber auch
Mitglied im Ausschuss für Bauen Wohnen
und Stadtentwicklung
Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren im
Vorfeld dieser Debatte wo wir über den
WSF sprechen habe ich noch mal Ihnen die
Protokolle des Deutschen Bundestages
geschaut um mir nochmal zu
vergegenwärtigen wie das eigentlich
aussah als vor zweieinhalb Jahren der
WSF damals unter den frisch aufkommenden
Bedingungen der corona-pandemie auf dem
Weg gebracht wurden und das ist ganz
erstaunlich was man für Zitate in der
damaligen Plenardebatte zu diesem Thema
finden kann vielleicht einfach einen
kleinen Ausschnitt dazu mal hier
präsentiert damit sie ein Gefühl dafür
kriegen wie relativ manche
Wertevorstellungen von einigen hier im
Haus anscheinend sind damals wurde an
diesem Puls zum Beispiel geäußert es
gibt Situationen da muss man vielleicht
auch Entscheidungen treffen deren
Wirkung man nicht bis zum langen Ende
Bedenken und sehen kann aber man muss
Entscheidungen treffen um in der
Situation der größten Not diese zu
bekämpfen das hat ja damalige
Wirtschaftsminister Peter Altmaier CDU
hier im Plenum gesagt und ihr damaliger
Fraktionsvorsitzender Herr Brinkhaus
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Union
der sagte folgendes wir werden in dieser
Krise liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
auch entscheiden denn das Schlimmste
dass man einer Krise machen kann ist
sich wegzuducken und nichts zu tun zu
warten bis der Sturm vorübergeht weise
Worte weise Worte die Herr Brinkhaus
damals gesprochen hat aber die die sich
heute in einer vergleichbaren Situation
der Krise und mit genau diesem
Instrument vor Augen leider nicht mehr
so recht erinnern wollen und es geht
noch weiter sie haben damals großherzig
in der Debatte im Deutschen Bundestag
den damaligen demokratischen
Oppositionsfraktion Grünen und FDP dafür
gedankt dass sie trotz seiner unklaren
Gemengelage in der nicht bis ins letzte
Detail schon alles entschieden war ihre
staatspolitische Verantwortung auch in
der Opposition wahrgenommen haben und
eingelöst haben dass die demokratische
Mehrheit zusammensteht warum sind sie
heute eigentlich nicht zur selben
staatsmännischen und freundlichen Tat
fähig meine Damen und Herren
stattdessen verstecken sie sich hinter
ziemlich fadenscheinigen Argumenten 200
Milliarden Euro aber man wisse ja gar
nicht so genau wofür das eigentlich
aufgewendet werden soll sagen sie das
eigentlich auch ihren sechs
Ministerpräsidenten die in der
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz unter Punkt
4 genau dafür ihre Zustimmung gegeben
haben unter der Nennung von 200
Milliarden Euro als Rahmen für die
Kredit Ermächtigung steht dort in
einzelnen Bullet Coins sie können das
alles nachlesen wofür genau das am Ende
gedacht ist zur Implementierung einer
gaspreisbremse für den Grundbedarf und
für die Industrie in Deutschland zur
Absicherung und zwar kurzfristig der
strompreisbremse in Deutschland für die
Liquiditätshilfen von Betrieben gerade
energieintensiven in Deutschland und
vielem anderen mehr da steht das drin
das hat ihren Ministerpräsidenten
gereicht um zu sagen jawoll dahinter
versammeln wir uns und vielleicht ist
das einfach der Unterschied zwischen
Leuten die Verantwortung tragen in dem
Land und Leuten die es jetzt einfach mal
ganz nett finden aus Position ein
bisschen verkehren zu können
in ihrem Entschließungsantrag den ich
sehr genau gelesen habe steht drin mit
vollen Händen würde das Geld jetzt hier
ausgegeben werden
übermäßige haushaltspolster liege die
Regierung hier an es ist eine
verräterische Sprache die da zum
Ausdruck kommt denn übermäßige
haushaltspolster unterstellt nicht wer
vielleicht noch ein paar Detailfragen
hat zur genauen Umsetzung sondern
übermäßige haushaltspolster unterstellt
jemand der findet dass das einfach eine
unangemessen große Hausnummer ist über
die wir hier sprechen das wäre aber eine
spannende Einschätzung in Zeiten indem
BDI und andere davon ausgehen dass wir
vielleicht noch viel mehr brauchen
werden in den nächsten Jahren um die
Volkswirtschaft in Deutschland und die
Gesellschaft durch diese Krise
durchbekommen zu können sie klettern ja
schon am Anfang der Krise
sehen Sie es ist das gute Recht der
demokratischen Opposition die
Regierungskoalition zu kritisieren
Ungeduld zum Ausdruck zu bringen und
auch harte Fragen zu stellen es ist auch
das gute Recht der demokratischen
Opposition dabei keine wirklich
greifbaren eigenen Pläne vorzulegen wenn
wir auch heute in der Debatte noch mal
gemerkt haben wir erwarten aber von den
demokratischen Opposition auch Klarheit
und Wahrheit darüber wo sie eigentlich
selbst in dieser Debatte steht und dazu
gehört dass man nicht behauptet aus
politisch handwerklichen Gründen heute
nicht zuzustimmen wenn man eigentlich
aus politisch taktischen Gründen nicht
zustimmen will sie wollen heute
sie wollen heute aus politisch
taktischen Gründen nicht zustimmen weil
die nächsten Monate schwierig und
ungewiss werden und sie da lieber kein
Risiko eingehen stehen sie doch einfach
dazu und schreiben Sie dann nicht in
ihren Entschließungsantrag es braucht
eine pragmatische Politik die das Wohl
des Landes über wahl- und
parteitaktische Fragen stellt diesem
Anspruch wenn sie leider heute selbst
nicht gerecht das erledigt die Koalition
für Sie und da streiten wir jetzt auch
zur Tat und stimmen zu ich danke Ihnen
recht herzlich
Kevin Kühnert SPD Generalsekretär und
natürlich auch Mitglied des Bundestages
mit einem Rückblick in frühere Debatten
und zum Thema Kreditaufnahme wo sie
nötig gewesen ist jetzt wird hier das
eine und andere abgestimmt werden und da
hat das Wort die Bundestagspräsidentin
zu Tagesordnungspunkt 26b
Abstimmung über die Beschlussempfehlung
des Haushaltsausschusses zu dem Antrag
der Fraktion der AFD mit dem Titel keine
neuen Schattenhaushalte begründen der
aus das empfiehlt unter Buchstabe b
seiner Beschlussempfehlung auf
Drucksache 4.094 den Antrag der Fraktion
der AFD auf Drucksache
3.944 abzulehnen wer stimmt für diese
Beschlussempfehlung
das sind die Fraktionen die Linken SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grünen FDP und
cdu/csu-fraktion wer stimmt dagegen das
ist die afd-fraktion
Enthaltungen
sehe ich nicht dann ist die
Beschlussempfehlung so angenommen
Abstimmung über den Antrag der Fraktion
Die Linke auf Drucksache
3.976 mit dem Titel Schuldenbremse für
2023 aussetzen wer stimmt für diesen
Antrag das ist die Fraktion DIE LINKE
wer stimmt dagegen die übrigen
Fraktionen im Hause Enthaltungen
keinen dann ist der Antrag abgelehnt
Abstimmung über den Antrag der Fraktion
SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP auf
Drucksache
4.058 mit dem Titel Beschluss des
Deutschen Bundestages gemäß Artikel 115
absatz 2 Satz 6 und 7 des Grundgesetzes
hierzu liegt uns eine Erklärung nach §
31 unser Geschäftsordnung vor
nach Artikel 115 absatz 2 Satz 6 des
Grundgesetzes ist zur Annahme des
Antrags die absolute Mehrheit das sind
369 Stimmen erforderlich die Fraktionen
der SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP
haben namentliche Abstimmung verlangt
die Abstimmung erfolgt in der westlobby
sie haben zur Abgabe ihrer Stimme nach
Eröffnung der Abstimmung 20 Minuten Zeit
ich bitte die Schriftführerin und
Schriftführer sehr der Daumen ist hoch
die vorgesehenen Plätze einzunehmen
damit sind die Plätze an den Uhren
besetzt
ich eröffne die namentliche Abstimmung
über den Antrag die abstimmungsuhren
werden um
10 Uhr
[Musik]
41 42 geschlossen
das bevorstehende Ende der namentlichen
Abstimmung wird Ihnen rechtzeitig
bekannt gegeben
so und das nochmal zur Information hier
geht es noch einmal um eine weitere
Ausnahme von der Schuldenbremse denn der
Staat die Bundesregierung muss ja neue
Kredite aufnehmen 200 Milliarden Euro
das ist der sogenannte Abwehrschirm und
um diese überhaupt aufnehmen zu können
um das erstmal zu ermöglichen dazu muss
jetzt hier in diesem Antrag dieser
Antrag eine Mehrheit finden im Parlament
dass das erstmal möglich ist und wenn
dieses Ergebnis da ist wenn also das
Parlament mehrheitlich dafür gestimmt
hat die Schuldenbremse auch an dieser
Stelle noch einmal auszusetzen dann wird
im Anschluss an die jetzt zu beginnende
Debatte in der es um einen Antrag der
Unionsfraktion geht und um einen Antrag
der afd-fraktion dann wird auch noch mal
über das Gesetz zur Änderung des
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds dessen
Reaktivierung und dessen Neuausrichtung
auch noch mal namentlich abgestimmt
werden aber zunächst man muss ja das
Parlament entscheiden dass diese neue
Kreditaufnahme von maximal 200
Milliarden Euro getätigt werden
der erfolgreiche Politik jetzt geht es
um das Thema Rohstoffe und da gibt es
wie gesagt zwei Anträge zum einen aus
der Unionsfraktion zum anderen auf der
afd-fraktion die beim ersten Überfliegen
was ich hier vorhin mal zwischendurch
gemacht habe sich sehr sehr ähneln es
geht in erster Linie darum neue
rohstoffpartnerschaften zu finden es
geht darum Deutschlands
Rohstoffabhängigkeit zu reduzieren auf
unterschiedliche Art und Weise und das
wird jetzt hier gleich diskutiert werden
während die Bundestagspräsidentin noch
mal ermahnt dass eine gewisse Ruhe
einkehren möge im Plenarsaal und wenn
Sie sich das mal angucken ist doch jetzt
einiges angewusel da das ist
naturgemäß so weil nämlich die
Abgeordneten sich jetzt natürlich
teilweise auf den Weg machen zu den
abstimmungsurnen hier in der Lobby auf
der plenarsaalebene des Bundestages
jetzt aber der erste Redner zu diesem
Debatten Punkt am Pult Stefan Rolo
ruhenhof aus der Unionsfraktion
corona-pandemie hat der deutschen
Wirtschaft einen Vorgeschmack darauf
gegeben was es heißt wenn wichtige
Rohstoffe knapp werden die Folge massive
Preissteigerung eine gedrosselte
Produktion und Produktionsstopps mit
staatlichen Stützungsmaßnahmen hat die
große Koalition 2020 2021 eine
Pleitewelle in der deutschen Wirtschaft
verhindert die corona-krise hat gezeigt
der Produktionsstandort Deutschland ist
ohne eine verlässliche
Rohstoffversorgung massiv gefährdet und
der russische Angriffskrieg macht
deutlich Deutschland ist nicht nur bei
Energierohstoffen sondern auch bei
vielen mineralischen Rohstoffen von
einzelnen Ländern viel zu abhängig
geworden Rohstoffe die im Zweifelsfall
auch als geostrategische Waffe
eingesetzt werden gegen Deutschland
gegen Europa liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen lassen Sie uns gemeinsam daran
arbeiten unsere Rohstoffabhängigkeit zu
reduzieren damit sich in unserer
Volkswirtschaft auch damit sich unsere
Volkswirtschaft auch in stürmischen
Zeiten international behaupten kann um
dieses Ziel zu erreichen brauchen wir
einen Bündel von Maßnahmen eine
Fokussierung liebe Freundinnen Freunde
von den Grünen allein auf die
Kreislaufwirtschaft reicht hier bei
weitem nicht aus denn bei zwei Drittel
der von der EU-Kommission als kritisch
eingestuften Rohstoffe liegt die
Recycling gerade bei unter einem Prozent
unter einem Prozent das unterstreicht
wir müssen beim Recycling deutlich
besser werden aber wir müssen uns auch
beim Rohstoffabbau im In- und Ausland
viel stärker engagieren
denn nur dann werden wir in Deutschland
eine hohe Wertschöpfung und
vielversprechender Arbeitsplätze sichern
können denn gerade in
Zukunftstechnologien sind kritische
Rohstoffe zwingend erforderlich ohne
skandium keine Elektrolyse ohne Platin
kein Rechenzentrum ohne Seltene Erden
keine E-Autos über 90 Prozent der in der
EU verarbeiteten Seltenen Erden kommen
heute aus China liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die Zahlen zeigen sehr deutlich
es besteht dringender Handlungsbedarf
Deutschland und Europa sollten weder bei
der digitalen Transformation noch bei
der klimatransformation vom Wohlwollen
Chinas Russlands oder anderer Länder
abhängig sein
von diesen Hintergrund müsste die
Bundesregierung jetzt eigentlich alles
daran setzen die rohstoff-bezugsländer
zu diversifizieren deutsche Unternehmen
in Drittländern bei Explorationen
Genehmigung Abbau und Verarbeitung
politisch und finanziell deutlich
wirksamer zu unterstützen etwa durch
eine verstärkte Nutzung bestehender
rohstoffpartnerschaften oder durch neuer
Partnerschaften und Handelsabkommen
stattdessen bringt das Grün geführte
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium das bereits
ausverhandelte eu-freiheitsabkommen mit
dem Rohstoff leihreichen Land Chile
hingefahren warum weil die Grünen das
nachhaltigkeitskapitel nachverhandeln
wollten um ihre Parteibasis zu
besänftigen liebe Freundinnen und
Freunde von den Grünen hören Sie endlich
mit ihrem parteipolitischen Spielchen
auf dies schadet der Europäischen Union
und Deutschland massiv machen sie
endlich das was der Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland jetzt dringend braucht und
was auch sie für ihre Energiewende
benötigen setzen Sie mit Hilfe von
rohstoffpartnerschaften und
Handelsabkommen alles daran unsere
rohstoffbezugsquellen zu diversifizieren
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen unser
Blick sollte sich auch auf die heimische
Rohstoffgewinnung richten Deutschland
verfügt über einige energetische und
mineralische Rohstoffvorkommen die
bisher jedoch nicht genutzt werden Liebe
ampelfraktion ihr Koalitionsvertrag
zielt auf eine Erleichterung des
heimischen Rohstoffs ab das ist
angesichts der angespannten
geoparlotischen Lage umso wichtiger es
ist richtig aber nach fast einem Jahr
ampelregierung drängt sich die Frage auf
wie ernsthaft verfolgen sie eigentlich
dieses Ziel
denn zu der geplanten zu der geplanten
Novellierung des Bergrechts gab es im
Mai ein Fachgespräch das
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium lud
insgesamt 30 Experten ein
Rechtsanwälte Vertreter des ökoinstituts
Landes- und Bundesbeamte darunter war
jedoch nur ein einziger Vertreter der
rohstoffgewinnenden Industrie eine echte
Einbindung der Industrie hat bis heute
nicht stattgefunden und bei der
laufenden Novellierung des
raumordnungsgesetzes muss man die
Erleichterung für den
Rohstoffabbau mit der Lupe suchen das
ist kein Fortschritt das ist Stillstand
also ziehen sie endlich die Praktiker
heran damit die geplante Novellierung
des einschlägigen Gesetzes der
einschlägigen Gesetze einen
tatsächlichen Beitrag zur
Rohstoffsicherung leistet
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Ereignisse der letzten Jahre haben
gezeigt eine verlässliche
Rohstoffversorgung ist für unsere
Volkswirtschaft existenziell deutschland
braucht ein Gesamtkonzept zur
Rohstoffsicherung das neben dem bereits
genannten Punkten auch die strategische
Bevorratung von kritischen Rohstoffen
etwa mit Hilfe der einer Rohstoff
bevorratungsrücklage umfasst und
Maßnahmen zur effizienteren Ressourcen
Nutzung vorsieht wir als Union haben in
unserem antragsdiziert aus welchen
Bestandteilen ein gesamtkommen
Gesamtkonzept bestehen sollte liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von den
Regierungsfraktionen das ist die von
ihnen so oft geforderte konstruktive
Oppositionsarbeit sie haben die Chance
unserem Antrag heute zu folgen und die
Weichen richtig zu stellen wir sind
gespannt wie konstruktiv sie sind vielen
Dank
Stefan ruhedorf aus der Unionsfraktion
hat den Antrag seiner Fraktion hier
vorgestellt es geht um die
Rohstoffabhängigkeit Deutschland es geht
um die Rohstoffsicherung die deutsche
Industrie macht sich da auch sehr große
Sorgen insbesondere was die sogenannten
Seltenen Erden angeht jetzt Sebastian
Rohloff für die SPD-Fraktion zu sagen
auch wenn es die Aufmerksamkeit des
Hauses wahrscheinlich nicht erhöht ich
glaube die meisten von ihnen kennen das
Brettspiel die Siedler von Catan und das
mag einen ganz vereinfachen der
Vergleich sein aber es bringt schon auf
den Punkt wie die deutsche Wirtschaft
funktioniert wenn man nicht die nötigen
Rohstoffe hat um sich durch
Verhandlungsgeschick die Rohstoffe die
man fehlt nicht organisiert dann hat man
keine Chance zu gewinnen und genau das
gilt auch für die deutsche Wirtschaft
die Ampel hat den Wert von Rohstoffen
erkannt und ich freue mich dass die
Union dieses Thema hier drei Wochen
nachdem wir den deutsch-französischen
Aufschlag zum EU-Gesetz über kritische
Rohstoffe
diskutieren hier auf die Tagesordnung
setzt der Antrag verspricht einiges und
wie ich sie an der Stelle gelegentlich
sage die Analyse ist auch oft richtig
und einige Forderungen ich werde darauf
eingehen finden meine Unterstützung
spannend wird wenn man ins Detail geht
und ganz oft reden wir auch nicht über
viel Neues mal sehen wir gucken mal zum
Beispiel fordern Sie die Unterstützung
von unternehmerischen
rohstoffaktivitäten im Ausland am
Beispiel der japanischen Agentur yorkmek
ja richtig steht aber auch schon im
deutsch-französischen Aufschlag haben
wir vor drei Wochen schon aufs Gleis
gesetzt sie fordern neue
rohstoffpartnerschaften und die
Diversifizierung wir haben es gerade
wieder gehört auch das ist richtig Frau
Dr Brandner aber in Südamerika der
Bundeskanzler und der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister in Kanada
dementsprechend sind wir auch da schon
dran die Einbindung des Themas Rohstoffe
in den nationale Sicherheitsstrategie
hat Annalena baerbock schon thematisiert
und ist auf dem Weg und die
Praktikerinnen und Praktiker die bei der
Novellierung des Bergrechts eine Rolle
spielen sind auch schon
dementsprechend sind wir da auf Linie
aber wir haben es schon aufs Gleis
gesetzt während sie heute darüber reden
wollen korrekt dass wir eine größere
Diversifizierung brauchen insbesondere
was die Abhängigkeit von China betrifft
wir wissen auch dass China mit Blick auf
seltener Erden wahrscheinlich ein
wichtiger Handelspartner sein kann aber
wir haben spätestens am Beispiel von
Russland gesehen warum das kein
sinnvollen Entwicklung ist und
dementsprechend müssen wir da Vorsicht
walten lassen und andere Alternativen
klar ist auch und das ist der nächste
Stichpunkt der in diesem Zusammenhang
immer kommt dass das lieferkettengesetz
gerade vor diesem Hintergrund dringender
erforderlich ist denn je klar ist auch
dass das für die Unternehmen keine
zusätzliche Belastung sein darf und dass
das gut umsetzbar ausgestaltet werden
muss wir brauchen es aber gerade mit
Blick auf die Menschenrechtssituation in
schwierigen Ländern mit denen wir jetzt
teilweise noch Handel treiben um so
dringender und deswegen dürfen wir
keinesfalls aufs lieferkettengesetz
verzichten oder es verzögern
ernüchternd ist leider dass sie sich in
dem Antrag wieder vor allem auf große
abbauvorhaben
fokussieren ich weiß nicht warum sie
kleinere Bergbauvorhaben immer so ein
bisschen ignorieren weil ich glaube dass
das auch eine Möglichkeit sein kann die
Vielzahl der Projekte und das Angebot
auf dem Markt zu erhöhen glaube dass die
ein bisschen ein Schatten da sein führen
und das finde ich ein bisschen schade im
Übrigen hat das Kabinett ja am Mittwoch
den 15 Bericht der Aktivitäten des Fonds
für Rohstoffe und der einzelnen
rohstoffabkommen zur Kenntnis genommen
und beschlossen und da können wir sehen
dass wenn starken entwicklungseffekt in
diesem Bereich haben leider
konzentrieren wir uns da im Moment noch
ein bisschen zu sehr auf agrarrostoffe
und Institutionen ich glaube daran
sollten wir mal drüber nachdenken dass
zu verändern und auch da zu dieser
infizieren
ich glaube wir brauchen mutige Schritte
ich kann mir zum Beispiel gut vorstellen
dass wir mittelfristig so eine Art
Rohstoff Google Maps brauchen das klingt
jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen naiv aber
als Grundlage kann es Geologie
datengesetz dienen die Daten die man da
hat kann man auf breiter aufstellen kann
man ergänzen und kann dann entsprechend
gucken welche potenziellen
Rohstoffvorkommen man hat und das zum
Beispiel bei der Planung oder dem Abbau
nutzen und da müssen die Länder prüfen
inwieweit man auf die Daten zugreifen
kann und inwieweit wir da auch zum
Beispiel noch einen Explorationsprogramm
des Bundes dazu schalten können und ich
glaube diese innovativen Ideen braucht
es wir haben in diesem Bereich eine
hervorragende Forschungslandschaft wir
müssen aufpassen dass die durch die
fehlende Nachbesetzung von Lehrstühlen
zum Beispiel nicht ausgedünnt wird und
wir müssen
Alternativen zu den
importierten Rohstoffen finden wo immer
es möglich ist mein Kollege Tews wird
auf die Kreislaufwirtschaft noch
reingehen weil selbstverständlich klar
ist dass man rohstoffstrategien nicht
ohne Kreislaufwirtschaft denken kann es
war völlig klar jedes Produkt was
zumindest teilweise recyclebar ist muss
nicht neu hergestellt werden und dafür
braucht es keine Rohstoffe und das ist
ein ebenso wichtiger Punkt wie das
Förderprogramm nachwachsende Rohstoffe
aus dem Landwirtschaftsministerium da
werden innovative biobasierte Produkte
besonders gefördert zum Beispiel
bioverbundwerkstoffe aus naturfördern
brauchen wir für den Karosseriebau
Porsche macht das schon in kleinen Serie
und das ist genau der richtige Weg den
wir weitergehen müssen
darüber hinaus kann ich mir vorstellen
dass wir eine Agentur für
sprunginnovation schaffen und da zum
Beispiel also die gibt es aber die
ausweiten und wir da eine Challenge
Unabhängigkeit von kritischen Rohstoffen
zum Beispiel schaffen das hätte glaube
ich auch was Fortschritte was im
Kreativwettbewerb betrifft etc guten
Effekt und anhand des von der EU
definierten Begriffs kritischen
Rohstoffe können alle Interessierten vom
Forschungsunternehmen bis zum kleinen
garagenbastler wenn man so möchte Ideen
da einreichen und wir wissen auch dass
gute Ideen auch schon spontan entstanden
sind und auch irgendwo herkommen wo man
sie vielleicht nicht unmittelbar
erwartet neue Fördermethoden um aus
alten Abraum halten noch kritische
Rohstoffe zu gewinnen Wind aus meiner
Sicht ebenso förderwürdig wie neue
Produkte die bisher kritische Rohstoffe
gebraucht haben aber anders konstruiert
werden und eben ohne kritische Rohstoffe
klarkommen neu entwickelte Materialien
die dieselben Eigenschaften dann aber
haben werden genauso förderwürdig aus
meiner und ich habe ja gesagt das ist
auch durchaus Übereinstimmungen gibt ich
unterstütze zum Beispiel ihre Forderung
die Verordnung zur Natur auf Zeit
möglichst schnell umzusetzen ich glaube
dass das gerade auch für
Planungsverfahren sind voll sein kann
und ja wir haben alle den großen Auftrag
die Steigerung der Akzeptanz in der
Bevölkerung wenn es um die Förderung von
Rohstoffen geht egal ob das die
Kiesgrube vor Ort ist oder was anderes
zu steigern zum Abschluss
und das finde ich dann auch wieder
schade machen sie ja wie gesagt gute
Vorschläge sagen aber das geht alles nur
im Rahmen der verfügbaren
Haushaltsmittel also riesenvorbehalt und
wir wissen alle dass die Bäume im
Haushalt gerade alles andere als in den
Himmel wachsen dementsprechend entwertet
dass ihren Antrag ein bisschen das finde
ich sehr schade ich freue mich aber auf
die weitere Diskussion mit ihnen weil
vielleicht kriegen wir auch zusammen was
sind in der Koalition auf jeden Fall
aber vielleicht gibt es auch
konstruktive Momente der cdu/csu wir
freuen uns drauf vielen Dank
Sebastian Rohloff aus der SPD-Fraktion
ein paar Informationen rund um die
Rohstoffstrategie der Bundesregierung
die gibt es seit 2010 und sie ist dann
2020 fortgeschrieben worden im Moment
wird an einer weiteren Fortschreibung
gearbeitet und sich steuert maßgeblich
die deutsche
Rohstoffpolitik und dazu gleich mehr
jetzt malte Kaufmann aus der
afd-fraktion
in der deutschen Wirtschaft brennt es
mittlerweile lichterloh drastische
energieverteuerung und ein zunehmender
Mangel an verschiedensten Rohstoffen und
Vorprodukten sind die größten Probleme
beide Probleme haben einige gemeinsame
wesentliche Ursache und zwar die
weltfremde ökosozialistische Ideologie
der Grünen
muss man einfach so sagen
akuter Rohstoffmangel und historischer
Einbruch deutscher Export ist die Folge
einer verfehlten
Außenwirtschaftspolitik es gibt beinahe
keinen Wirtschaftsbereich der vom
Rohstoffmangel nicht betroffen wäre Holz
Metalle Gummi Kunststoff sind in
Deutschland zu Mangelware geworden
Unternehmen in den Bereichen
baumaschinenbau Elektrotechnik
Medizin Chemie und viele andere klagen
über überdimensionale Preissteigerungen
und akute Lieferengpässe
die Folgen sind drastisch
Preiserhöhungen Inflation
auftragsverluste eine Pleitewelle die
sie noch im Ausschuss diese Woche
verleugnet haben und mehr noch durch das
unsägliche
lieferkettengesetz ein langjähriger
Wunsch der Grünen laufen deutsche
Unternehmer aller Branchen nudengefahr
für irgendwelche Missstände bei ihren
ausländischen Lieferanten in Haftung
genommen zu werden weil die dortigen
Rahmenbedingungen möglicherweise nicht
ihren Standorts entsprechen Stichwort
feministische Außenpolitik das ist doch
ein Irrsinn meine Damen und Herren
so ein Unfug würde vielen anderen
Ländern wie beispielsweise China nicht
im Traum einfallen dort akzeptiert man
dort akzeptiert man den bewährten
Grundsatz hören sie gut zu dass jedes
Land seine gewachsene Kult ich habe
beispielsweise China gesagt man
akzeptiert dass jedes Land seine
gewachsene Kultur hat die man nicht
oberlehrerhaft von außen verändern darf
und deshalb verfolgen diese Länder eine
pragmatische Außenhandelspolitik die
sowohl vom dem eigenen Volk dient als
auch der wohlstandsmehrung in den
Lieferländern Deutschland dagegen frönt
einer Ideologie getriebenen grünen
Außenhandelspolitik die am Ende gar
niemandem dient weder uns selbst noch
den potenziellen Lieferländern
außerdem müssen wir weg von einer grünen
Energiepolitik die uns schadet denn
unser Land braucht günstige Energie
nicht teure sie wollen ja teure Energie
Kollegen von den Grünen wir brauchen
aber günstige Energie als Lebensader für
die deutsche Wirtschaft und wir brauchen
grundlastfähigen Strom deshalb
sehen sie endlich ein dass ein
Industrieland wie unseres ohne Kernkraft
nicht am Leben bleiben wird ihr fauler
Kompromiss drei AKWs 100 Tage länger zu
laufen zu lassen ist doch völlig
ungeeignete Energiekrise unseres Landes
auch nur im Ansatz zu bewältigen deshalb
lassen sie die noch laufenden drei
Kernkraftwerke dauerhaft am Netz holen
Sie auch diejenigen drei wieder zurück
die derzeit noch
reaktivierbar sind öffnen Sie Nord
Stream 2 dann wird der Strompreis sofort
sinken und Bürger und Unternehmen können
endlich aufatmen vielen herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
bevor ich die nächste Rednerin Aufrufe
komme ich noch mal zurück zu
Tagesordnungspunkt 26c die Zeit für die
namentliche Abstimmung ist gleich vorbei
ist noch ein Mitglied im Haus dass noch
nicht abgestimmt hat
gut dann
dann jetzt schnell dann machen wir noch
mal mit dem
dann reden wir noch ein wenig über
dieses wichtige Thema dann rufe ich auf
für die Bundesregierung als nächste
Rednerin die Parlamentarische
Staatssekretärin dr Franziska Brandner
so und während einige jetzt ganz schnell
in die Lobby laufen um noch abzustimmen
die Parlamentarische Staatssekretärin
beim Bundesminister für Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz
bei dem bei der Rohstoffversorgung vor
erheblichen Herausforderungen erstens
corona-pandemie russische Angriffskrieg
haben deutlich gemacht wie fragil manche
rohstofflieferketten sind zweitens im
Bereich metallischer Rohstoffe bestehen
zentrale Abhängigkeiten vor allen Dingen
von China 3 seit langem wissen wir um
die strategische Bedeutung von
Rohstoffen für Zukunftstechnologien und
die grüne Transformation
leider Herr hohenhoff hat die
Vorgängerregierung hier zu lange
gezögert
und
deswegen gehen wir es jetzt aktiv an wir
machen eine aktive Rohstoffpolitik und
ich skizziere in drei Punkten was das
bedeutet erstens diversifizieren durch
europäische und internationale
Zusammenarbeit wir beleben die
rohstoffpartnerschaften die es bis jetzt
gibt die aber hauptsächlich bis jetzt
auf dem Papier existieren und wir
hinterlegen Sie jetzt mit konkreten
Projekten mit konkreten
unternehmerischen Aktivitäten und das
ist auch richtig und wichtig
sie haben zu Chile gesprochen
offensichtlich dem EU viele Abkommen
offensichtlich wissen sie nicht dass die
chilenische Regierung das Abkommen noch
nachverhandeln möchte um genau im
Rohstoffbereich eine Erleichterung für
die
weitererarbeitung in ihrem Land zu
bekommen das ist das was der aktuelle
Stand ist und das ist auch etwas was wir
unterstützen es ist in unserem Interesse
das Weiterverarbeitung nicht nur in
China stattfindet sondern auch in
Ländern wie Chile das ist unser Ziel und
da gehen wir auf die chilenische
Regierung zu genau das sind die
Partnerschaften der Zukunft wie wir sie
uns vorstellen
und natürlich geht es uns auch darum
dass die Rohstoffe die wir die wir
fördern die wir unterstützen werden zu
fördern auch auf hohen ökologischen und
sozialen menschenrechtlichen Standards
abgebaut werden absolut wir wollen keine
Kinderarbeit in den Rohstoffen die wir
unterstützen wir wollen keine
Wasserverschwendung sondern die beste
deutsche Technologie um Wasser zu sparen
um grüne Energie damit zu verknüpfen das
ist der Vorteil den wir als Deutsche
haben wenn wir in diese Länder gehen
dass wir die besten Technologien haben
dass wir eben auch mit indigenen Völkern
zum Beispiel umgehen können unsere
Unternehmen und das ist das was uns
ausmacht und was wir nicht aufgeben
sollten was in ihrem Antrag aber fehlt
und deswegen appellieren wir nicht nur
ein Unternehmen zu diversifizieren
sondern wir unterstützen Sie gezielt
dabei das reicht von der klassischen
projektabsicherung über ufk-garantien
bis zu und das ist das was wir jetzt
planen Beteiligung an Rohstoffgewinnung
weiterverarbeitungs- und
recyclingprojekten zum Beispiel durch
einen gemeinsamen deutsch-französischen
wenn möglich sogar europäischen
Rohstofffonds und das ist auch das Gebot
der Stunde dass wir hier nicht drei
national handeln sondern im europäischen
Verbund es macht keinen Sinn dass wir
uns jetzt gegenseitig zwischen
Deutschland und Frankreich mit den
Italienern auch noch den
rohstoffwettbewerb ausliefern sondern
hier müssen wir gemeinsam an einem
Strang ziehen und deswegen haben wir
deutsch-französisch ein Input in den
europäischen Prozess gegeben das ist für
mich der richtige Ansatz hier gibt es
nur eine europäische Antwort die wir
auch gemeinsam gut vorbereiten
und zweitens Recycling Recycling
Recycling das haben sie vorhin selber
angesprochene hohenhoff wir haben hier
Recyclingquoten die sind ja wirklich
nicht akzeptabel dafür dass diese
Rohstoffe so wertvoll sind müssen wir
hier dringend Vorankommen dafür werden
wir auch bei uns bei den Normen
Standards wo nötig rechtliche Grundlagen
verbessern um das in Deutschland und in
Europa voranzubringen wir brauchen mehr
Forschung herolf sie haben es richtig
angesprochen ja da gibt es tolle neue
Technologien für die Substitution für
die Effizienz die müssen wir fördern und
voranbringen da sind ganz neue
Möglichkeiten das ist die Zukunft ja und
da rein müssen wir jetzt auch
entsprechend investieren dritter Punkt
die Versorgungssicherheit rückt auch die
heimische Gewinnung von Rohstoffen in
den Fokus das gehört dazu und hier
führen wir einen Dialog eine
gesellschaftliche Debatte um mehr
Akzeptanz des heimischen Rohstoffs auch
zu fördern das ist eine schwierige
Debatte und wir werden sie gut führen
dass wir am Ende eine höhere Akzeptanz
dafür haben es ist nämlich darum dass
wir international die Partnerschaften
haben dass wir bei dem Recycling
Vorankommen die Stoffe die schon bei uns
sind sie besser noch mal immer wieder
nutzen und drittens beim heimischen
Rohstoffabbau mit ökologisch hohen
Standards auch unseren Beitrag zur
Rohstoffversorgung sichern das sind die
drei Schritte die drei Pfeiler einer
unserer aktiven Rohstoffpolitik und wenn
die Opposition dabei mitmacht dann freue
ich mich darüber und lade Sie ein
herzlich mitzumachen herzlichen Dank ich
freue mich auf eine aktive neue
Rohstoffpolitik die wir als Deutschland
endlich voranbringen können danke
ich komme nochmals zurück zu
Tagesordnungspunkt
26c die Zeit der namentlichen Abstimmung
ist jetzt vorbei
ich schließe jetzt diese ich schließe
die Abstimmung und ich bitte die
schriftführerinnen und Schriftführer mit
der Auszählung zu Beginn das Ergebnis
der Abstimmung wird Ihnen später bekannt
gegeben
damit komme ich zurück zu
Tagesordnungspunkt 27 und nächster
Redner für die Fraktion DIE LINKE ist
Christian Laier
ist wirtschaftspolitischer Sprecher der
Linksfraktion und das Ergebnis der
namentlichen Abstimmung zur einem
weiteren Aufheben der Schuldenbremse für
die für den 200 Milliarden Euro
Rettungsschirm werden wir so in gut 10
bis 15 Minuten bekommen es geht um eine
extrem hohe Abhängigkeit bei Rohstoffen
Deutschland ist der fünftgrößte
rohstoffverbraucher der Welt und mehr
als 99 Prozent der im Bergbau gewonnenen
Metalle kommen aus dem Ausland und dann
wird im unionsantrag etwas nebulös von
geopolitischen Spannungen gesprochen und
ich sage reden wir doch offen über die
beiden Elefanten im Raum das ist die
Rohstoffabhängigkeit von Russland und
das ist die Rohstoffabhängigkeit von
China zu Russland 44 Prozent der
Deutschen Nickel und palladiumimporte
41% der titanimporte und 22 Prozent des
rohraluminiums kommen aus Russland und
deswegen stehen diese und weitere
Rohstoffe auch aus guten Grund nicht auf
der CDU Sanktionsliste im Übrigen
genauso wenig wie das Gas aber was wir
im laufenden Wirtschaftskrieg gemeinsam
gelernt haben ist die Gegenseite schlägt
dort zurück wo sie es sich aussucht das
können wir uns nicht aussuchen sie
schlägt dort zu wo es weh tut wie wir an
den aktuellen Energiepreisen merken
meine Damen und Herren
so und dann reden wir über den zweiten
Elefanten im Raum das ist die
Rohstoffabhängigkeit von China es gibt
eine Reihe von relevanten Rohstoffen wo
wir bis zu 100 Prozent von chinesischen
Importen abhängig sind und im Gegensatz
zu Russland bleibt diese Abhängigkeit
auch längerfristig ein Problem und zwar
weil fast die Hälfte der weltweiten
bergbauproduktion von China betrieben
wird das lässt sich nicht einfach so weg
diversifizieren meine Damen und Herren
so und warum sage ich das weil sich im
Zuge der Rivalität mit China auch die
Wirtschaftspolitik verschärft im
klassischen Imperialismus galt noch the
Flag follows the trade heißt staatliche
Aktionen orientierten sich am
ökonomischen Handel heute im Niedergang
der westlichen Hegemonie gilt andersrum
the trade follows the Flag heißt
Handelskonflikte orientieren sich an
geopolitischen Konflikten und da stehen
wir möglicherweise auch bei China vor
die USA hat bereits ein halbleit Embargo
gegen China fängt und
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck hat in treuer
gefolter Gefolgschaft eine robustere
Handelspolitik gegenüber China
angekündigt ich kann nur eines sagen wir
sind gut beraten die Finger von einem
weiteren Wirtschaftskrieg zu lassen
diesmal mit China meine Damen und Herren
und dafür gibt es Gründe unsere
Abhängigkeit von vielen mineralischen
Rohstoffen aus China ist größer als die
von Gas aus Russland und was der
laufende Wirtschaftskrieg in der
Bevölkerung schon anrichtet da sehen wir
doch hoffentlich meine Damen und Herren
und ähnlich wie im Wirtschaftskrieg mit
Russland gilt diesmal es gibt kaum ein
Land in der EU das so abhängig ist von
Handel mit China wie Deutschland
deswegen darf man da nicht blindlings in
den nächsten Wirtschaftskrieg
hineinlaufen ich sage Ihnen noch ein
Handelskonflikt und diesmal ein härterer
und schlimmerer als der mit Russland das
wird die Bevölkerung nicht mitmachen das
hält die nicht aus meine Damen und
Herren
und es gibt noch einen weiteren Grund
sie wollen die Abhängigkeit von
russischen gasreduzieren und erneuerbare
Energien ausbauen aber deswegen wird die
Abhängigkeit von chinesischen Rohstoffen
ansteigen und warum bei seltenen Erden
sind wir zu 100 Prozent auf chinesische
Importe angewiesen die braucht man aber
für Solaranlagen und Windkraftanlagen
bei Graphit sind wir zu 90 Prozent auf
chinesische Importe angewiesen die
braucht man aber auch für Solaranlagen
und bei Gallium sind wir zu 60% auf
chinesische Importe angewiesen und auch
das braucht man für die Solarindustrie
das heißt die Nachfrage nach Öl und Gas
wird langfristig sinken aber die
Abhängigkeit von Metallen und Erden wird
genau deswegen ansteigen für das
Industriezeitalter waren fossile
Brennstoffe die Treiber aber in der
Energiewende und in der Digitalisierung
braucht es jetzt mehr Kobalt Lithium
Seltene Erden und so weiter und so fort
und deswegen jetzt am Ende noch mal
langsam zum Mitschreiben die
wirdifizierung Kreislaufwirtschaft
Recycling alles richtig alles wichtig
lassen sie um Gottes Willen die Finger
von einem weiteren Wirtschaftskrieg mit
China die Bevölkerung wird das nicht
mittragen sie gefährden Digitalisierung
sie gefährden die Energiewende und sie
gefährden die Klimaziele dankeschön
Christian leyhe für die Linksfraktion wo
er wirtschaftspolitischer Sprecher ist
in dieser Debatte in der es um
Deutschlands Rohstoff Abhängigkeit geht
aber auch im Strategien diese Rohstoffe
zu sichern durch Partnerschaften
beispielsweise und dazu jetzt Reinhard
Huben aus der FDP-Fraktion auch er ist
wirtschaftspolitischer Sprecher
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
ich möchte doch auf die Vorredner ein
bisschen eingeben auch noch kennen sie
als seriösen Abgeordneten
der sich einbringt in die Themen die er
vorträgt und deswegen sage ich zum
ersten ihr Antrag hat
Aspekte die wir gerne debattieren wollen
also deswegen vielen Dank für diese
Begleitung und da sage ich immer
andersrum eines Prozesses den die
Bundesregierung im Grunde ja schon
längst angestoßen hat also deswegen wir
können gerne debattieren ich halte es
für ein wichtiges Thema sie haben das
richtig dargestellt und Rohstoffpolitik
hat vor allen Dingen eine
Langfristperspektive und ich möchte nur
eine Bemerkung zur letzten
Legislaturperiode machen aus welchem
Gründen auch immer
ist eben in der letzten
Legislaturperiode in dem Bereich
ja fast gar nichts passiert
und so ist das mit dem Timing von
Anträgen manchmal komme ich auch nicht
so ganz
zeitlich geschickt
ich bin gestern später da gewesen ich
weiß nicht ob sie da waren Kolleginnen
und Kollegen von der Unionsfraktion der
BDI hat gestern Abend eine glaube
fünfstündige Veranstaltung zum Thema
Rohstoffe gemacht und dort hat unter
anderem der Wirtschaftsminister selbst
gesprochen da war ich auch noch nicht
anwesend aber Frau Brandner hat dann in
einer Debatte für die Bundesregierung
Stellung genommen und ich sage Ihnen
dort hat sich die Bundesregierung
positioniert zu dem was wir im
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart haben wir
haben nämlich im Koalitionsvertrag eines
festgestellt
wir können nicht einerseits sagen wir
wollen Industriestandort bleiben
und gleichzeitig erwarten dass andere
Länder zu möglichst günstigen Preisen
und waren und Rohstoffe liefern wir aber
andererseits sozusagen im eigenen
Vorgarten nicht bereit sind
entsprechende Maßnahmen zu ergreifen und
das haben wir in den
Koalitionsverhandlungen erkannt und auch
so formuliert und das fängt natürlich
bei der Kiesgrube an
endet aber meine Damen und Herren weil
Seltene Erden angesprochen worden sind
es gibt Aktivitäten im Erzgebirge um
seltene Erden vorkommen die wir in
Deutschland haben zu heben und dann ist
es unsere Aufgabe die Rahmenbedingungen
zu schaffen dass diese Maßnahmen in
Deutschland erfolgreich schnell aber
eben auch umweltverträglich umgesetzt
werden und das ist unser Ziel
und noch mal zu den Ausführungen
Rohstoffabhängigkeit
das ist aber doch im Grunde deutsche
Realität seit 200 Jahren seit dem
Deutschland
Industrie Land geworden ist waren wir
immer abhängig von Rohstofflieferung ja
wir hatten vor allen Dingen Steinkohle
Braunkohle und Ärzte für Stahl
aber eben andere Rohstoffe noch nie also
wenn dann Kautschuk zum Beispiel als
Beispiel für
Rohstoffmangel vorgegeben wird Herr
Kollege muss ich sagen ich habe noch nie
einen Kautschukbaum in Deutschland
wachsen sehen aber das ist vielleicht
eine andere Kleinigkeit und eine
Bemerkung noch zu den weltpolitischen
Bedingungen
meine Damen und Herren hier in diesem
Hohen Hause wenn es einen
Handelskonflikt mit China geben wird
dann werden wir den hier nicht auslösen
das wird auch nicht die Europäische
Union sein das wird ganz alleine davon
abhängen wie sich Peking in Zukunft
verhält vor allen Dingen im Verhältnis
zu teilbar
und
meine Damen und Herren da geht es aber
auch nicht um die Frage ob wir gewinnen
oder verlieren ich weiß ja nicht wie Sie
das sehen aber ich finde wir haben eine
gewisse politisch moralische
Verpflichtung freie Demokratien zu
verteidigen so wie wir das im Moment mit
der Ukraine tun und so werden wir es
dann in Zukunft auch tun müssen
meine Damen und Herren
die Bundesregierung ist
in der Arbeit Frau Brandner hat das
dargestellt sie sammelt im Moment ganz
schön viele bonusmalen wenn ich das so
richtig verstanden habe um weltweit
Partnerschaften voranzubringen wir sind
unterwegs mit den unterschiedlichsten
Handelsverträgen um die
Rahmenbedingungen zu verbessern und
jetzt wird die Union wieder sagen wann
wird denn ceta ratifiziert da gilt immer
doch das Wort von Bernd Westphal in
diesem Herbst also meine Damen und
Herren die Bundesregierung ist aktiv
Rohstoffe sind ein langfrist-thema wir
haben damit begonnen und werden es
langfristig nicht nur mit ausländischen
Partnern sondern auch hier in
Deutschland lösen vielen Dank
Reinhard Huben der wirtschaftspolitische
Sprecher der FDP-Fraktion in der Debatte
zu zwei Anträgen aus cdu/csu und
afd-fraktion zur Rohstoffe Sicherung in
Deutschland drei Säulen hat die
Rohstoffversorgung in Deutschland einmal
die Sicherung und Ausbeute heimischer
Rohstoffe dann geht es um Importe und
ein ganz wichtiger Punkt und der auch
noch weiter nach vorne rücken soll sind
ist das Recycling von Rohstoffen
Bernhard Loos für die Unionsfraktion für
den Standort Deutschland von
herausragender Bedeutung unsere
Rohstoffversorgung steht auf drei Säulen
die auch in einer Rohstoffstrategie eine
zentrale Rolle spielen muss
ersten Förderung heimische Rohstoffe
zweitens Import von benötigten
Rohstoffen sowie Gewinnung von
sekundarrohstoffen durch Recycling
mit unserem Antrag wollen wir auf einige
grundlegende Entwicklungen reagieren
erhebliche nachfrageveränderungen
Zunahme von Handelsstreitigkeiten
Marktverzerrungen durch staatliche
Eingriffe und dominieren die Marktmacht
einzelne Erzeuger oder Erzeuger Länder
im Jahr 2011 hatte die damalige
unionsgeführte Bundesregierung der
deutschen rohstoffagentur beauftragt ein
rohstoffmonitoring zu kritischen
Rohstoffen zu entwickeln die Unternehmen
regelmäßig auf
preis-strategien mitzuhelfen dieser
Ansatz muss weiter ausgebaut werden
in der nationalen Sicherheitsstrategie
müssen konkret die Maßnahmen benannt
werden mit denen eine sichere und
bezahlbare Rohstoffversorgung
gewährleistet werden sollen der FAZ von
17.10 22 konnten wir entnehmen dass
Deutschland eine
wirtschaftssicherheitspolitik braucht so
die Parlamentarische Staatssekretärin dr
Brandner
wenn dies heißt gemeinsam mit der
europäischen Partnern gemeinsam mit der
Industrie entsprechende Vorsorge zu
treffen dann unterstützen wir dies
wir wollen auch das geprüft wird ob die
Einführung einer
rohstoffbevorratungsrücklage die
Resilienz von Unternehmen
gegenüberlieferketten Unterbrechungen
stärken wurde wir wollen aber nicht dass
die Überlegungen der Bundesregierung
bedeuten könnten dass man der Industrie
vorschreiben will was in welchem Umfang
wie zu bevorraten wäre
Deutschland ist bei vielen Rohstoffen
zumeist vollständig auf den Import
angewiesen wir müssen daher verstärkt
daran arbeiten alternative
Versorgungsmöglichkeiten zu erschließen
die Substitution von primär durch
Sekundärrohstoffe muss hierzu einen
wichtigen Beitrag leisten die in
Deutschland bereits hochentwickelte
Kreislaufwirtschaft soll sich zukünftig
noch entschiedener am Leitbild der
Ressourceneffizienz orientieren und noch
stärker auf die Rohstoffversorgung der
deutschen Wirtschaft ausrichten
wichtig aus unserer Sicht den Austausch
zwischen Industrieforschung und
Verwaltung zu verbessern um die
Gewinnung und Nutzung von sekundären
Rohstoffen gezielt voran zu bringen den
Entsorgungswirtschaft selbst
stellt bereits gut 15 Prozent den
Deutschland benötigten Rohstoffe bereit
durch den Rückgriff auf
Sekundärrohstoffe werden jährlich
rohstoffimpotte mit einem Wert von mehr
als 10 Milliarden Euro eingespart
Verantwortung für eine gesicherte
Rohstoffversorgung heißt aber auch bei
uns im eigenen Land Rohstoffe abzubauen
und nicht nur im Ausland zu beschaffen
es braucht ein größeres Engagement bei
der Gewinnung von Rohstoffen im Inland
die ampelkondition hat im
Koalitionsvertrag vor einem Jahr
folgende schöne zwei Sätze geschrieben
wir wollen unsere Wirtschaft bei der
Sicherung einer nachhaltigen
Rohstoffversorgung unterstützen den
heimischen rohstoffaufbau erleichtern
und ökologisch ausrichten wir wollen das
bundesbankgesetz modernisieren
aber aber herum was ist bisher gesehen
und wo überhaupt soll die Reise hingehen
das fragen sich nicht um die
betreffenden Unternehmen zum Bereichen
gibt es zum Beispiel im Bereich der
gipsindustrie Fakt ist
Ria gibt es halt aktuell einen Anteil
von nur noch ca 55% im Deutschen gibt es
Rohstoff Mix ein verstärktes Recycling
wurde die gesamte Thematik mengenmäßig
nur etwa 10% entlasten ebenso wenig
können Importe die entstehenden
Versorgungslücken ausgleichen deshalb
bedarf es sowohl der neuerschliessung
von gipsabbauflächen als auch der
Beseitigung bestehende Hindernisse bei
erforderlichen produktsteigerungen
existierenden gewinnungsarealen
Verantwortung für eine Energieversorgung
heißt zu prüfen ob und wie wir in
Deutschland mehr Öl und Gas gewinnen
können und eben nicht nur fracking-gas
in den USA Einkaufen nach dem Motto aus
den Augen aus den Sinn
dazu gehört es eine neue Genehmigung für
die offshore Forderung von Öl und Erdgas
jenseits der erteilten Rahmen
Betriebserlaubnisse zu ermöglichen und
das Verbot von kommerzieller
unkonventioneller frackingvorhaben auf
Basis des Berichts der
Expertenkommission Fracking zeitnah zu
überleben den Kurswechsel des grünen
Bundeswirtschaftsministers ging dem
Wortlaut gegen den Wortlaut der das
ampelkoalitionsvertrages in Sachen
nordsee-gasforderung und die positiven
Signale zu schaffen der
völkerrechtlichen Voraussetzung
unterstützen wir ausdrücklich ich betone
aber auch es darf keine Rückschritte
durch eine neue rot-grüne
Landesregierung in Niedersachsen geben
das wäre das falsche Signal ich danke
Ihnen für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
Bernhard los aus der Unionsfraktion
aber bevor ich dem nächsten Redner das
Wort gebe noch bekannt wie die
Abstimmung ausgegangen ist
der Beschluss des Deutschen Bundestages
gemäß Artikel 115 absatz 2 Satz 6 und 7
des Grundgesetzes abgegeben wurden 665
Stimmkarten mit ja haben gestimmt 390
mit Nein 239 36 haben sich enthalten
gemäß Artikel 1915 absatz 2 Satz 6 des
Grundgesetzes ist die Mehrheit der
Mitglieder erforderlich das sind 369 ja
stimmen der Antrag ist mit der
erforderlichen Mehrheit angenommen
und die Anzahl der
zustimmenden liebten relativ naja sogar
im oberen Bereich zu dem was möglich
gewesen wäre maximal 416 Stimmen bringt
ja die Ampel Koalition hier auf die
Waage das heißt damit ist auch gleich
klar nach Ende dieser Debatte die im
Moment noch läuft wird dann aufgerufen
die Abstimmung über das über den über
die Gesetzesänderung zum
stabilisierungsfongesetz zur
Reaktivierung und Neuausrichtung des
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds zunächst
Michael Tews aus der SPD-Fraktion in der
Debatte über Rohstoffe
um Rohstoffabbau um jeden Preis
Nachhaltigkeit Fehlanzeige Menschen
würde Menschenrechte Fehlanzeige und
Umweltschutz sowieso Fehleranzeige so
kann man nachhaltige Umweltpolitik
nachhaltige Rohstoffpolitik auf keinen
Fall machen da sind die Unternehmen und
die Menschen in Deutschland schon längst
weiter
das können nicht die Antworten sein
insbesondere auch nicht in so einer
Krise man kann mit den Ideen von
vorgestern nicht die Probleme von morgen
lösen wir werden innovative Lösungen
brauchen und da bietet Deutschland
einiges insbesondere im Bereich der
Kreislaufwirtschaft und schade dass sie
da eben diesen Lösungen nicht mehr Raum
eingeräumt haben auch in ihren Anträgen
in Deutschland kann da eine ganze Menge
mehr passieren wir müssen Transformation
voranbringen Transformation unserer
Wirtschaft hin zu einer
Kreislaufwirtschaft und das ganze so
schnell wie möglich die Menge an
abgebauten Rohstoffen auf dieser Welt
ist nun mal oder abbaubaren Rohstoffen
ist begrenzt gleichzeitig aber steigt
der Ressourcenbedarf rasant an 2016 wird
der voraussichtlich doppelt so hoch sein
wie 2011 haben wir noch 2011 79
Gigatonnen Material Materialien
verbraucht werden es 2016 schon 167 sein
und statt jetzt nun versuchen zu
versuchen einen Kampf um Rohstoffe vom
Zaun zu brechen und dort Lösungen zu
finden wäre es dringend geboten
Kreislaufwirtschaft wirklich jetzt neu
zu denken voranzubringen aus
ökonomischen aber natürlich auch aus
ökologischen Gründen
der Abbau von primären Rohstoffen
versucht verursacht nahezu immer mehr
Treibhausgase als ein Recyclingprozess
ein bekanntes Beispiel ist Aluminium für
Recycling von Aluminium benötigt man nur
fünf Prozent der Energiemenge wie für
die Herstellung aus primärrohstoffbauxit
europaweit werden im stofflichen
Recycling jährlich über 100 Millionen
Megawattstunden Primärenergie eingespart
dazu kommt dass der Abbau und die
Verarbeitung von Rohstoffen heute
bereits für 90 Prozent der Bio des
Verlustes an Biodiversität
verantwortlich ist
Kreislaufwirtschaft und das ist meine
feste Überzeugung ist eben gelebter
Klima und Umweltschutz und schafft
Unabhängigkeit von den volontiven
volantilen Märkten aber auch
Unabhängigkeit in Krisensituationen wie
wir das jetzt erleben und deswegen
glaube ich dass wir im Bereich der
Kreislaufwirtschaft noch viel
Möglichkeiten haben hier Lösungen zu
finden
die Europäische Union importiert 78
Prozent des benötigten Lithium aus einem
einzigen Land wir haben das vorhin schon
gehört aus Chile
diese Abhängigkeit sollte anders genug
sein das Lithium Recycling in
Deutschland mit Hochdruck voranzutreiben
die Industrie ist Deutsch in Deutschland
setzt bisher nur 12 Prozent Rohstoffe
aus recyclingprozessen ein das müssen
wir dringend ändern wir müssen
Produkte recyclingfähig herstellen wir
brauchen eine einsatzquote für retiklate
und Liebe Union das haben sie jahrelang
verhindert und immer dagegen gesprochen
wir müssen durch geeignete
Rahmenbedingungen die Absatz von
rezikladen und sekundärmaterialien
fördern und dadurch eine
Investitionssicherheit für
kreislaufwirtschaftsunternehmen schaffen
das alles sind Maßnahmen für die sich
die SPD-Fraktion schon lange einsetzt
und die Union immer wieder blockiert hat
da wurde das nicht dass die Förderung
der Kreislaufwirtschaft in ihrem Antrag
ganz hinten vorkommt ich hoffe dass es
keine Wertung der Kreislaufwirtschaft
denn das hätte sie nicht verdient
die Union hat in den letzten Jahren
Maßnahmen zur Förderung der
Kreislaufwirtschaft immer wieder mit dem
Hinweis blockiert man dürfe die
Wirtschaft nicht zu sehr belasten man
müsste auf die EU warten und nur eins zu
eins umsetzen das sind verpasste Chancen
vor allen Dingen
und das zeigt auch eigentlich ihr Antrag
die Anträge die uns vorliegen die sind
rückwärtsgewandt und wenig innovativ
vielen Dank
dann müsste jetzt auch klatschen
ja so schnell kann es gehen mit einem
Redebeitrag Michael Tews war das aus der
SPD-Fraktion nächster Redner wird sein
Bernd Schattner aus der afd-fraktion die
ja ebenfalls einen Antrag hier vorgelegt
hat die nachhaltige Sicherung und
Versorgung mit strategischen Rohstoffen
ist das Rückgrat einer Industrienation
wie Deutschlands der hier vorliegende
Antrag der Union hat allerdings mal
wieder einige Lücken und Widersprüche
sie wollen zum einen
rohstoffpartnerschaften identifizieren
ausbauen und neu abschließen tragen aber
gleichzeitig die für Deutschland
desaströße Sanktionspolitik gegen
Russland als größten rohstoffexporteur
der Welt mit
gleichzeitig schreiben sie in ihrem
Antrag dass Sie Ina bägung ziehen
umweltschädliches Fracking in
Deutschland zu betreiben um auf der
anderen Seite die Rohstoffgewinnung im
Zuge der Transformation hin zu
Klimaneutralität zu unterstützen was
darf es denn jetzt bitte davon sein
meine Damen und Herren mehr Heuchelei
geht doch gar nicht sie belügen den
Wähler bewusst und in voller Absicht sie
wollen anders sein sie wollen eine
Opposition sein sie sind weder anders
geschweige denn eine echte Situation in
ihrer Regierungsverantwortung besiegen
sie die Kohle und Atomausstieg und
unterstützten Werte die man als links
grün aber definitiv nicht als
konservativen Politik bezeichnen kann
für uns als AFD steht aktuell fest
deutsche Energie und Strom geht nur mit
Kohle und Atom ihr Antrag ist immer gut
gemeint aber handwerklich schlecht
gemacht denn er versucht nur die
Symptome zu lindern traut sich aber
nicht an die Ursachen heran es spricht
für sich dass diejenigen die immer
wieder von sich als Volksparteien
sprechen immer stärker gegen das
deutsche Volk agieren statt des Versuchs
eine diplomatische Lösung in dem Krieg
zwischen Russland und der Ukraine zu
finden wählen Sie den Weg einer weiteren
Eskalation sie sind auf der Seite derer
die weiter Waffen und andere
rüstungsglieder und die Kriegsgebiete
liefern wollen und tragen damit massiv
zur Eskalation bei der Lösungsweg von
uns als der AFD ist ein anderer wir
versuchen immer wieder die
Bundesregierung zu einer diplomatischen
Option zu bewegen leider besetzt umsonst
für uns überraschend ist vor allem die
Position der Grünen als angebliche
Konfliktparteien diesen als
Friedenspartei in diesem Konflikt töten
sie im Wahlkampf noch groß mit Sprüchen
wie keine Waffen den Kriegsgebiete so
liefern sie heute nicht nur in die
Ukraine sondern weiterhin auch an
Staaten die zum Beispiel Saudi-Arabien
aber in Sachen Doppelmoral kennen sie
sich ja wunderbar aus wenn sie genauso
viel Energie in die Bewältigung der
Strom und der Gaskrise investieren
würden wie beim Feiern nach ihrem
Parteitag müssten die deutschen
Steuerzahler die diese Party
finanzierten weder frieren noch Angst um
ihren Wohlstand haben meine Damen und
Herren Rohstoffe wie Gas und Öl zu
bezahlbaren Preisen sind momentan nur
mit einem fairen Handel mit Russland zu
erreichen mit teuren Importen aus den
USA und Katar machen wir uns nur noch
abhängiger als wäre es jetzt schon sind
liebe Kollegen gestatten Sie mir am Ende
meiner Rede noch ein paar Worte zu den
Ereignissen in Ludwigshafen bei mir in
meinem Heimatort ich danke meinem
Fraktionsvorsitzenden kinopropalla dass
er in seiner gestrigen Rede bereits in
beiden ermordeten Handwerkern gedacht
hat als Reinhard Felser ist es für mich
das Schweigen der Landesregierung und
allen voran Ministerpräsidentin
Marie-Luise Dreier jedoch das
enttäuschendste überhaupt ein weiteres
mal versagt sie bei einer Tragödie ich
mag mir gar nicht vorstellen wie die
Reaktion ausgefallen wäre wenn es sich
bei den beiden ermordeten eben nicht um
zwei deutsche Handwerker gehandelt hätte
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
das Wort gebe ich an die Kollegen Dr
Sandra detzer für Bündnis 90 die Grünen
und sie ist Mitglied im
Wirtschaftsausschuss
[Applaus]
liebe Kollegen und Kollegen
es dann der Kollege Huben hat schon
gesagt haben wir sehr sehr interessante
diskutiert auf dem rohstoffkongress des
BUND der deutschen Industrie des BDI
ganz breit war Unternehmer innen war
Politik war Zivilgesellschaft vertreten
und es war vollkommen klar dass ich alle
einig sind auch die zeitenwände ist bei
der Rohstoffpolitik angekommen die
internationalen Rohstoffmärkte und das
ist glaube ich ganz zentral diesen Punkt
wirklich auch gerade aus unionssicht mal
durchzudenken
die internationalen Rohstoffmärkte
Stellen eben nicht mehr zu jeder Zeit
die gebrauchten Rohstoffe zur Verfügung
und wenn Sie das dann doch tun dann eben
nicht zu Preisen die wettbewerbsfähig
sind für unsere Industrie und genau
diese
Verfügbarkeit auf diese Preisstabilität
die brauchen wir natürlich das haben wir
jetzt gesehen dass das beim Gas des
Problem ist und es gilt ganz besonders
natürlich im Punkto kritische im Punkto
strategische Rohstoffe die wir jetzt
brauchen für die Transformation unserer
Wirtschaft da geht es um Lithium
Magnesium Kobalt die Vorredner erinnern
haben das aufgezählt das bedeutet aber
auch es ist Zeit für eine echte
Rohstoffstrategie in Deutschland und vor
allen Dingen in Europa wir diskutieren
in Europa momentan sehr sehr viel über
die Frage gemeinsamer Gaseinkauf
gemeinsame Gaspreise das ist im Kern
auch die künftige Debatte die wir über
Rohstoffe führen werden und ich bin der
parlamentarischen Staatssekretärin
brandta extrem dankbar dass sie dann
klugen Vorschlag gemacht hat zusammen
Frankreich wie wir in der Sache
weiterkommen können weil das ist genau
das wie die Operationalisierung auch
dieses deutsch-französischen Motors
funktionieren kann
und warum ist es jetzt so wichtig und
das ist glaube ich auch ein Punkt der
ein bisschen unterbelichtet ist im
unionsantrag warum brauchen wir diese
Rohstoff Souveränität weil wir wissen
dass wir Mittelstand dass wir unsere
Wirtschaft aber auch unsere Gesellschaft
besser schützen müssen vor massiven
Krisen das ist in der Vergangenheit
leider nicht genug passiert wir haben
leider gesehen dass ich ganz viele
politische Akteure darauf verlassen
haben eben dass der Weltmarkt diese
Rohstoffe zur Verfügung stellt und genau
deswegen ist diese Rohstoff Souveränität
zentral
an der Stelle fragt mich übrigens sehr
gefreut dass sie die jobmac erwähnt
haben die japanische rohstoff-agentur
Japan ist uns meines Erachtens ungefähr
zehn Jahre in der rohstoffsuveränität
voraus Japan hatte die zeitenwände
bereits 2010 china hat damals die
Einfuhr der seltenen Erden nach Japan
gestoppt und daraufhin hat die
japanische Regierung sich sehr sehr
kluge Gedanken gemacht über Rohstoff
Souveränität ich habe gestern und seit
längeren Tagen viel geredet mit der BGR
mit der deutschen rohstoffagentur derer
und die haben gesagt Mensch wir warnen
seit Jahren fast schon seit Jahrzehnten
vor Klumpenrisiko bei der
Rohstoffbeschaffung wir sind immer gegen
geschlossene Türen gelaufen es hat nicht
funktioniert davon was umzusetzen jetzt
ist es endlich soweit Rohstoffe sondern
aller Munde und das ist die gute
Nachricht wir haben hier in Windows
opportunity
Frau Kollegin sie kommen zum Ende bitte
ich komme zum Schluss niemand muss
globalen partner:innen aber auch
Wettbewerberinnen böses unterstellen und
es ist ganz klar dass wir für eine faire
Globalisierung so viel Kooperationen wie
möglich brauchen doch die Situation ist
Ernst der chinesische Marktanteil bei
den Rohstoffen ist zu hoch und deswegen
ist es gut dass rohstoffsouveränität das
Gebot der Stunde ist herzlichen Dank
sandra derzer hat ein wenig ihre Zeit
überzogen aber wir nutzen trotzdem die
Gelegenheit Ihnen schnell zu sagen was
sie denn mit BGR eben gemeint hat da
haben wir nämlich fix nachgeguckt das
ist die Bundesanstalt für
Geowissenschaften und Rohstoffe nicht
ganz unwichtig in dieser Debatte und
jetzt ist Hagen Reinhold dran aus der
FDP-Fraktion
beauftragt dafür maritime Wirtschaft
auch da gibt es ja tief im Meer durchaus
wichtige Rohstoffe ich beginne meine
Rede damit was zu beleuchten was wir
noch gar nicht so richtig auf dem Schirm
haben wir reden nämlich sehr oft davon
was wir für Rohstoffe jetzt gerade
brauchen und versuchen so in die Zukunft
zu schauen ich prognostiziere uns mal
wie wissen noch nicht wie der
rohstoffmix in zehn Jahren aussieht und
das auch gut und richtig so
warum sage ich das weil wir wenn wir
dieses Haus betrachten in den letzten
Jahren ganz andere Debatten haben noch
vor zwei Jahren Entschuldigung noch vor
zwei Jahren haben wir über Holz und
sandknappheit hier diskutiert die
Rohstoffstrategie die letzte ist gerade
mal zwei Jahre her 2020 das Wort Erdgas
steht dreimal drin und zwar im
Zusammenhang mit wir haben langfristige
Lieferverträge und deshalb
versorgensicherheit in Deutschland daran
sieht man schon es ändert sich was und
was brauchen wir dazu Forschung und
Entwicklung warum nämlich dann eine
Wirtschaft die selbst verstanden hat
dass eine immer höhere Nachfrage auf
immer knappere einzelne Materialien
stößt eine schlechte Zukunftsperspektive
hat und deshalb gibt es ja Leute die
sagen lasst uns doch aus Lithium in den
Akkus andere Materialien verwenden und
deshalb sind wir längst auf den Weg bei
Forschung und Entwicklung hin zu
Materialien die eine größere
Verfügbarkeit haben und auch eine
heimischee Verfügbarkeit und deshalb
schreibt sich diese
fortschrittsregierung nämlich auch
Forschung und Entwicklung auf ihre Fahrt
ist ein Teil der Lösung die wir brauchen
ich komme mal zu einem bemerkenswert war
eine Fraktion hat versucht
herauszufinden wie das funktioniert für
die nächsten Jahre vorauszuschauen und
das ist hier die Alternative für
Russland hier ist ja auch kein Wunder
eigentlich denn die haben sich ja von
Russland und von China haben sie auch in
ihrer Rede klar gemacht noch deutlich
mehr abgeguckt als wir bisher gedacht
haben nämlich wir können ein sehr
planwirtschaftlichen Ansatz nehmen das
sind Länder die das machen und das haben
sich abgeschaut und die wollen jetzt
nämlich die Bundesregierung auffordern
zu defanieren welche Gewerbe Zweige in
Deutschland in der Wirtschaft welche
Rohstoffe vorzuliefer und Endprodukte
für die nächsten Jahre brauchen das
wollen sie festschreiben das kann man
machen in Ländern die Erfolg Knechten da
kann man nämlich sagen wir bauen in den
nächsten fünf Jahren so und so viel
Autos und so viel Motorroller so zu mir
Waschmaschinen dann klappt das in einem
Land wie Deutschland was innovativ ist
was fortschrittlich ist klappt
Planwirtschaft nicht deshalb ist ihr
Antrag unsinnig und mehr nicht
sie sprechen davon dass wir in den
Ländern von den bürostoffe beziehen
tätig werden sollen das machen wir
längst mit
wirtschaftspartnerschaftsabkommen der EU
die nehme ich ungleichgewichtig darauf
achten wie wir mit Ländern umgehen indem
wir zum Beispiel kleineren Ländern
Zollfreiheit in die EU gewährleisten
während sie bei uns zu einer nehmen
können und warum machen wir das
europäisch und nicht so wie sie in ihren
Antrag schreiben wir sollen das
nationalstaatlich in Deutsch machen weil
kluge Gründungsväter der europäischen
der Europäischen Union längst erkannt
haben in Europa gibt es nur zwei Typen
von Staaten kleine Staaten und solche
die noch nicht verstanden haben dass sie
klein sind deshalb schließen wir uns
zusammen und Handeln europäisch war nur
so solche Abgaben durchzusetzen ist das
macht auch wenn man mal schaut wenn wir
über seltene Ebene reden das ist schon
angeklungen Seltene Erden haben wir auch
bei uns
Seltene Erden haben wir auch bei uns
aber die Veredelungsprozesse haben ihnen
starke Auswirkungen auf Menschen und
Umwelt und genau das ist der Grund warum
wir mit lieferkettengesetzen überprüfen
wollen wo wir sie herbekommen ist
übrigens auch der Grund warum wir sie
nicht in Europa produzieren obwohl wir
es könnten teilweise und deshalb ist
natürlich in einer Zeit die die
Unternehmen stark fordert zu
kontrollieren ob Lieferketten vielleicht
nicht ein zwei Jahre später zumindest so
umgesetzt werden wie sie vorgenommen
sind aber dass wir als Wirtschaftsnation
vorangehen und überprüfen ich habe dafür
keine toleranzia sie schreiben in ihrem
Antrag man sollte akzeptieren was in den
Ländern passiert gesellschaftlich und
auch arbeitstechnisch und nennen das
Toleranz also ich nenne Kinderarbeit
oder ich habe für Kinderarbeit weder
Toleranz noch sonst irgendwas übrig und
Lehne deshalb das ab
lassen Sie mich die letzten Sekunden
dafür verwenden zu sagen dass im
unionsantrag B1 aufgefallen ist nämlich
die fehlende Diskussion mit der
Wirtschaft zusammen für Rohstoffe zu
sorgen dafür hatten kluger liberale
Wirtschaftsminister mal die Deutsche
rohstoff-agentur unter anderem gegründet
um die Wirtschaft zu unterstützen und in
Gesetzesvorhaben wo sie es anprangern da
nimmt man sowas Verbandsanhörung und
Diskussion mit den unterschiedlichen
Akteuren das macht diese Bundesregierung
selbstverständlich deshalb ist ihr
Antrag in den Teilen die sie aus dem
Koalitionsvertrag abgeschlossen haben
sehr gut im Rest ausbeutwürdig danke
schön
und das war Hagen Reinhold aus der
FDP-Fraktion ihm wird jetzt folgen
Hans-peter Welsch aus der Fraktion CDU
CSU es geht weiter hier geht es
weiterhin um Rohstoffe und die
Abhängigkeit davon liebe Kollegen
die Ampel hat im Koalitionsvertrag ist
ja schon angesprochen worden verbesserte
Rahmenbedingungen für die Erkundung
heimischer Rohstoffe angekündigt das ist
also die Abteilung selbst gewinnen was
wir können aber bisher absolut keine
Initiative auf den Weg gebracht in
dieser Richtung die Sicherung der
Rohstoffversorgung ist essentiell für
unser Land und deshalb fordern wir von
der CDU CSU von dieser Regierung alle
Optionen müssen auf den Tisch und zwar
schnell
ein größeres Engagement Deutschlands bei
der Gewinnung von Rohstoffen im In- und
Ausland ist umgehend erforderlich neue
rohstoffpartnerschaften ist von Kollegen
schon ausgeführt worden enge
Zusammenarbeit mit den
EU-Mitgliedstaaten in der Zugang zu
kritischen und strategisch wichtigen
Rohstoffen ist auch im Krisen und
Kriegsfall existenziell die
Energiemärkte sind weitgehend europäisch
und am Ende hängen wir alle an denselben
Brennstoffen für uns darf das nicht
bedeuten dass wir die Hände in den Schoß
legen
dass wir die Hände in den Schoß legen
sondern uns einfach darauf verlassen
dass die europäischen Partner oder die
USA im Ernstfall uns versorgen werden
wir müssen selbst vorsagen und was zählt
ist die Tat Deutschland muss seinen
Beitrag leisten dass mehr es mehreren
sich die kritischen Stimmen bei
europäischen Partnern Deutschland muss
seinen Beitrag leisten als Gebot soll
ich europäischer Solidarität und eben
nicht mehr mit flatterstrom sondern mit
grundlastfähigen Energien und da ist von
dieser Regierung leider nicht zu
erwarten was wäre wenn Notfallpläne für
Lieferstopp gibt es nicht seit Monaten
ist klar im Bereich
Energieversorgung dass wir bis zum dass
wir zum Jahresende mit einer weiteren
Verknappung zu rechnen haben das Konzept
auf das wir warten heute morgen ist
diskutiert worden über 200 Milliarden
Überschriften nichts Konkretes ihr müsst
endlich mal aus dem Puschen kommen und
konkret was auf den Tisch legen was er
vorhabt in diesem Land
wenn man Beispiel nennen
bei den diesjährigen
Wirtschaftsgesprächen FAZ in Frankfurt
hat Christian Kullmann der evonik-chef
und Präsident des VCI die dramatische
Situation eine Beispiele Chemieindustrie
sehr passend beschrieben Frankfurt hatte
wenige Tage vorher in Sevilla in Europa
Cup gewonnen die Eintracht und da hat
sich das Bild eben aufgedrängt Strecke
Frankfurt Sevillas in 1830 km und
stellen sich vor und Zug der in
Frankfurt ankommt und dessen Ende noch
in Sevilla steht hat er die Frage den
Raum gestellt was glauben Sie wie lange
die deutsche chemische Industrie mit
diesen Zug voller gasdruckkesselwaggons
produzieren könnte sechs Stunden war die
Antwort sechs Stunden das zeigt das
Volumen was wir dort brauchen und wir
diskutieren das Ganze leider viel zu
viel zu sehr immer nur unter der
Überschrift in der Gas als Energieträger
für Chemie für Pharma für
düngemittelproduktion ist es
unverzichtbare produktionsrohstoff
und
da ist nicht nur hier beim Gas die
Abhängigkeit eben extrem hoch und damit
die Erpressbarkeit sondern auch bei
Rohstoffen sie sind schon einige davon
ausgezählt worden aufgezählt worden
Silizium pobalt Nickel auf
Herkunftsländer angewiesen deren innere
Verfasstheit häufig nicht gerade zum
Vorbild gereicht um es mal vor um uns
mal vorsichtig auszudrücken
Abhängigkeit von mineralischen
Rohstoffen Seltene Erden insbesondere
China ist erwähnt worden wir haben jetzt
gesehen im Umgang mit Russland Putins
Clique
zögert nicht davor zurück Energie als
Waffe einzusetzen und ebenso würden die
Kommunisten in Peking nicht zögern ihre
wirtschaftliche Macht gegenüber
deutschen Unternehmen auszuspielen rot
china macht schon jetzt druckt bei jeder
sich bietenden Gelegenheit wenn ihr
irgendwas nicht passt reden sie mal mit
den Freunden in Litauen da können Sie
interessante Geschichten erfahren wie
dort der Umgang zwischen Partnern im
außenwir der Bereich ist
wir müssen aktiv in den weltweiten
Wettbewerb um die Rohstoffe einsteigen
Energiewende Digitalisierung steigern
die Nachfrage nach Rohstoffen drastisch
und gleichzeitig verschärft der
ukrainekrieg die bereits vorhandenen
Lieferengpässe auch der links gelben
Ampel muss das langsam klar werden dass
ohne den Einsatz von vielfältigen von
vielfältigen Rohstoffen keine Produktion
keine Gebäude und kein Transport gibt
wenn die Ampel nicht bald initiativ wird
haben wir Stillstand in unserem ganzen
Land
die das hat nicht nur Auswirkungen das
hat nicht nur Auswirkungen auf
Arbeitsplätze Wohlstand das ist auch für
unsere Wehrhaftigkeit entscheidend ich
will Ihnen mal ein Beispiel nennen F35
haben sie gerade geschafft fünfte
Generation moderner Jet 700 Kilogramm
sogenannte selten Erdmetalle verarbeitet
darin das zeigt dass auch dort in der
Frage wie können wir unsere Sicherheit
garantieren dass ein wichtiger Punkt ist
der Wettlauf ist in vollem Gange und ich
hoffe dass schauen wir auf Lithium das
hier die Grünen auch bereits in wirklich
Schritte hier in Deutschland zu machen
wir wissen dass dieses begehrte Element
im Oberen Graben in salzigen thermal
Wasserreservoir in ansehnlicher Menge
vorhanden ist und das war alles nicht so
interessant bis silicium-ionen Batterien
sich durchgesetzt haben aber jetzt ist
es interessant und wir müssen daran
gehen und müssen das gewinnbar machen um
lithium-abhängigkeit vom Ausland zu
verringern
die die Themen kritische Rohstoff das
muss als als als strategisch wichtige
wichtiges Thema für die nationale
Sicherheit begriffen werden und da bin
ich gespannt vor allen Dingen auf die
Grünen wie sie auch zum Thema es ist
eben viel von Recycling gesprochen ist
ja auch wichtig aber natürlich müssen
wir auch eigene Ressourcen heben und wie
da diejenigen die ich immer nur erlebt
habe als welche die verhindern wollen
Nord in my backyard ist Prinzip ihrer
Politik dass wir dass wir dass wir das
Erleben mit ihnen da bin ich gespannt
drauf ich bin aus Hessen ich habe erlebt
den ersten Minister der Grünen Fischer
da bin ich gleich zu Ende der hat als
erstes planmäßig die nuklearme Betriebe
Lösung
als als nächstes sich die human die
human-insuli Produktion vorgenommen so
arbeiten die grüne der Praxis ich
bedanke mich für die Aufmerksamkeit und
danke der Präsidentin für Ihre Geduld
na da verabschiedet er sich noch höflich
von der
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin katrin
Göring-Eckardt in die Zeit war
abgelaufen für Klaus Peter wohl willst
zumindest für diese Rewe hier in der
Debatte über Rohstoffabhängigkeit
nächster Redner banked aus der
SPD-Fraktion liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger
eigentlich lohnt es sich ja kaum auf den
Antrag der AFD einzugehen der ist
technisch wieder mal schlecht gemacht
aber die Leute da draußen sollten
wirklich mal erfahren was das für eine
Truppe ist die hier sitzt die AFD
verbindet in perfider Weise jedes Ihrer
Anliegen mit der unerträglichen Hetze
gegen Andersdenkende und Andersgläubige
so verlangen sie dieses Mal allen
ernstens wir sollen anderen Ländern
keine lgbtq-rechte aufzwingen und lokale
Kulturen einfach tolerieren gerade eben
wurde es schon gesagt
kinderarbeitsklaven aber das können wir
nicht tolerieren das zeigt aber sehr
deutlich was Sie hier für Menschenbild
haben meine Damen und Herren das ist
schäbig und armselig
dabei sollte jeder wissen dass die
Einhaltung von Bürgern und
Menschenrechten nicht nur eine Frage von
Moral und Anstand ist sondern auch ein
Standortfaktor denn dort wo Menschen
frei leben und denken dürfen bringen Sie
sich in die Wertschöpfung ein und dort
lassen Investoren auch gerne ihr Geld
meine Damen und Herren doch leider
zeigen sie einmal mehr Anstand
Wirtschaft und wirtschaftliche
Fachkenntnis ist echt nicht ihr Thema
nun zu ihrem Antrag liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen von der Union als
energiepolitiker und zuständiger
Berichterstatter für das Thema
Windenergie es ist mir natürlich ein
Anliegen dass wir die Energiewende
vorantreiben und die Wertschöpfung
Deutschland halten und weiter ausbauen
es sind
344.000 Arbeitsplätze in Deutschland die
es in den erneuerbaren Energien gibt das
sind 40.000 mehr als in der chemischen
Industrie mal so eben das zeigt das
Potenzial was dahinter steckt was hat
das alles mit sicherer Versorgung zu tun
ziemlich viel denn zum Beispiel für die
Produktion von Windenergieanlagen werden
bis 2040 weltweit etwa 22 Millionen
Tonnen verschiedene Rohstoffe benötigt
Stahl Zink Kupfer das Ganze aus der
ganzen Welt aus Chile Südafrika aus sehr
sehr viel insofern Wahnsinn sie ja in
ihrem Antrag ziemlich wichtige Anliegen
aus der falschen Perspektive heraus
rohstoffpartnerschaften und eine
Diversifizierung der rohstoff-kellen
sind wichtig das ist gekauft alles gut
aber etwas verwundert bin ich da schon
denn viele Punkte die sie bereits schon
in der sind bereits schon Teil der
Rohstoffstrategie der letzten
Bundesregierung und da waren sie glaube
ich schon dabei und wir haben von Frau
Dr Brandner ja gehört dass das hier
weiter angepasst wird und weiter
forciert wird also sie werden hier
kalten Kaffee auf und wie immer und wie
das der Kanzler schon angedeutet hat
wenn sie in Korn finden sind wir dabei
schon das Mehl zu malen und den Kuchen
zu backen also von so her brauchen wir
das gar nicht gut anzugucken das passt
soweit schon aber was ist mit den
Umwelt- und klimaschutzaspekten auch
diese spielen bei der Frage der
Rohstoffgewinnung und des
rohstoffimports eine immer größere Rolle
dazu mal ein Beispiel der Methanausstoß
der muss deutlich reduziert werden denn
Methan fällt zum Beispiel bei der
Gewinnung und Veredelung von fossilen
Brennstoffen an beim Transport in EU
oder auch nach Deutschland auf 20 Jahre
betrachtet ist das Zeug 83 mal
klimaschädlicher als CO2 es ist das ja
gut dass wir die methanstrategie
gemeinsam mit der Wirtschaft weiter
forcieren aber in ihrem Antrag dazu
findet sich kein Wort was ist mit den
sozialen Aspekten Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
Schaffung von Wertschöpfung Jobs
umweltklimaschutz Einhaltung von Bürger
Menschenrechten das alles muss
zusammengedacht werden und dazu in dem
Antrag kein Wort
lassen sie sich noch ein bisschen was
sagen zum Thema rohstoffabhängigkeiten
und vor allem Diversifizierung man darf
ja ruhig nochmal daran erinnern dass die
Ampelkoalition in einem Jahr die
rohstoffabhängigkeiten jetzt abbauen
muss die die CDU geführt den
Bundesregierung 16 Jahre lang aufgebaut
haben meine Damen und Herren
und man darf auch noch mal daran
erinnern dass ausgerechnet diejenigen
die jetzt nach mehr Unabhängigkeit
brüllen 16 Jahre jede einzelne
Windenergieanlage in Deutschland
bekämpft und beklagt haben liebe
Kollegin von Kollegen von der Union das
geht eben nicht mehr heimische Rohstoffe
nutzen wollen aber gleichzeitig die
Nutzung des wichtigsten Rohstoffs über
Jahre und Jahrzehnte bekämpfen nämlich
Sonne und Wind und die gibt es auch noch
umsonst stattdessen versuchen sie im
Antrag ziemlich billig hinter durch die
Hintertür in dem Weg aufzumachen für
unkonventionelles Tracking für alle die
nicht genau wissen was das ist das ist
ein chemie-cocktail in der in den Boden
rein verpresst wird um den Klimakiller
Nr 1 nämlich Methan also Erdgas aus dem
Boden zu holen und das wollen sie hier
in Deutschland zulassen wir brauchen
Erdgas noch noch aber wissen Sie was
besser ist für die Versorgungssicherheit
und für das Klima als zwei
frackingbohrung eine frackingbohrung in
den USA die schon ausgebeutet wird und
die wir nutzen um von diesem Zeug
endlich loszukommen und endlich eine
klimaneutrale erneuerbare Welt zu
schaffen meine Damen und
weil die Zeit ist um letzter Satz wir
stellen uns grundlegend die Frage wie
wollen wir weitermachen wollen wir
weiter Kohlenstoff aus dem Boden holen
der 300 Millionen Jahre eingelagert
wurde den verbrennen und freisetzen wie
die Union oder wollen wir endlich in
einer neue saubere zukünftige Welt gehen
wie wir es tun als Ampel vielen Dank
auch Bengt muss hier ermahnt werden um
zum Ende seiner Rede zu kommen weil die
Zeit abgelaufen ist und was eine Kritik
am können wir unkonventionellen Fracking
angeht muss er gar nicht mal so sehr in
die Unionsfraktion gucken sondern kann
auch in die Koalition gucken denn diesen
Vorschlag hat genau gestern auch der
Bundesfinanzminister wieder aufgegriffen
weil Zitat man ja jede Energie im Moment
brauche egal wo man sie nur herholen
kann Katrin Henneberger ist die
vorletzte Rednerin in dieser Debatte und
sie gehörte Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen an
universitäts- und Klimakrise sowie die
Ursache der globalen Ungerechtigkeit
immer noch nicht verstanden oder noch
tragischer ihr wollt sie nicht verstehen
weil das würde bedeuten ihr müsstet eure
grundsätzliche Politik in Frage stellen
denn Rohstoffe sind endlich
Ökosysteme nicht grenzenlos belastbar
und die Kipppunkte unserer globalen
Klimasysteme drohen wir derzeit zu
überschreiten als Antwort auf diese
globalen Krisen kompromisslos
kompromisslos national und kurzsichtig
Handeln zu wollen ohne Rücksicht auf die
sozialen und ökologischen Folgen der
Förderung von Rohstoffen in anderen
Regionen der Welt dies ist neokolonial
in eurem Antrag macht ihr keinen Punkt
der die Einhaltung von Menschenrechten
indigenrechten oder Sozialstandards
betrifft ich sehe hier auch keine
Forderungen die die Auswirkungen auf die
lokale Umwelt durch Rohstoffabbau
überhaupt anspricht
statt auszubeuten als gäbe ist kein
morgen auf unserer Erde sollte es besser
das Ziel sein unseren Rohstoffbedarf in
absoluten Zahlen zu senken und achtsam
mit unserer Lebensgrundlage umzugehen
eine neue Rohstoffstrategie sollte die
Grundlage haben eine gerechte Wirtschaft
aufzubauen die nicht beruht auf
Menschenrechtsverletzungen Ausbeutung
von ArbeiterInnen und der Zerstörung
unserer Lebensgrundlage in der Wohlstand
gerecht verteilt wird ein gutes Leben
für alle Menschen statt ein reiches mit
Privatflugzeug nur für ein paar wenige
stattdessen möchte ich die möchte die
Union lieber exzessiv Fracking Öl und
Gas Förderungen betreiben ich war im
Sommer in einer Region Amazoniens wo
Erdöl gefördert wird vergisst Vergiftung
von wasserböden landname der Territorien
indigener Bevölkerung Ursache und
Verstärkung von gewaltsamen Konflikten
das sind die Auswirkungen ich habe eine
Frau besucht die aufgrund ihres langen
Engagements für Umweltschutz und gegen
die Erdölfirmen massiv bedroht wird so
sehr dass die Polizeischutz braucht auch
das sind die Auswirkungen einer
rücksichtslosen Rohstoffpolitik die sich
auch in ihrem Antrag wiederfinden da
wünsche ich mir doch etwas mehr Mut neue
Wege zu gehen
wenn wir
wenn wir nach dem Pariser Klimaabkommen
gehen dann darf es kein weiter so geben
denn neuen Erschließung von Erdöl und
Gasfelder stattdessen müssen wir sehr
dringlich unabhängig uns unabhängig
machen von den fossilen und die
erneuerbare Energiewende global ausbauen
in diesem Zusammenhang möchte ich mich
auch bedanken bei den Ministerien die
sich sehr engagieren für
klimapartnerschaften und diese weiter
ausbauen Fracking möchte ich nochmal
betonen mit Fracking fangen wir gar
nicht erst an wir werden nicht die
Verunreinigung von Grund und Trinkwasser
gefährden was wir wirklich brauchen ist
eine rohstoffwende eine
Kreislaufwirtschaft aufzubauen und
sozial wie ökologische Standards bei
Lieferketten umzusetzen vielen Dank
das ist eigentlich heute los
Esra Limbacher ist der nächste Redner
für die SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren es stimmt
unsere Versorgungssicherheit mit Energie
und Rohstoffen ist aufgrund des
russischen Angriffskrieges auf die
Ukraine der lieferkettenprobleme
weltweit und der weiterhin auftretenden
Auswirkungen der Pandemie mehr und mehr
gefährdet das trifft beispielsweise die
energieintensive Industrie sowie auch
viele mittelständische Unternehmen in
unserem Land besonders hart es wurde
heute schon viel gesagt ich will die
Möglichkeit nutzen heute auf einen
Treffen von vor zwei Tagen
hinzuweisen und zu berichten dass ich
mit der chemischen Industrie in unserem
Land nämlich dem VCI dem Dachverband der
Industrie hatte sind auch viele
mittelständische Unternehmen die in
diesem Bereich tätig sind haben wir
berichtet von den großen Sorgen und auch
den Nöten der momentan die momentan in
dieser Branche vorherrscht sie sind
doppelt betroffen weil sie zum einmal
von einem Erdgas als Energieträger als
wichtigen Energieträger haben und zum
anderen auch gleichzeitig als wichtigen
Rohstoff für viele
basis-chemikalien benötigen chemische
Erzeugnisse sind für 90 Prozent aller
Produktions Erzeugnisse in unserem
Unternehmen in Deutschland notwendig und
ohne diese Chemieindustrie das kann man
sagen steht die ganze Wirtschaft in
unserem Land still liebe Kollegen und
Kollegen warum sage ich das warum sage
ich das
weil wenn wir über Rohstoffe reden
glaube ich ist es unglaublich wichtig
den Grund überhaupt zu erfahren warum
wir die Rohstoffe hier in unserem Land
brauchen wir brauchen ihn vor allen
Dingen momentan um unsere Wirtschaft
auch am Leben zu halten um unsere
Industrie am Leben zu halten deswegen
will ich die Möglichkeit hier nutzen um
ein klares Bekenntnis zum
Industriestandort Deutschland zu
auszusprechen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich glaube genau in dieser Zeit
ist es besonders wichtig zu sagen wir
stehen zu unserer Industrie wir machen
alles damit sie weiterleben kann wir
lassen Sie nicht im Stich und deswegen
war es auch besonders wichtig heute zum
Tagesordnungspunkt zuzustimmen der
vorhin zur Abstimmung stand dass wir
eben auch die Entlastung die
gaspreisbremse auf dem Weg bringen
können da haben sie sich nicht nur
enthalten sondern auch dagegen geredet
ich finde das spricht Bände welche
Partei und welche Koalition und welche
Bündnisse hier in diesem Parlament
überhaupt noch hinter unter unserer
Industrie und unserer Wirt Aufstehen Sie
sicherlich nicht
deswegen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die Ampelkoalition hat sich in ihrem
Koalitionsvertrag ambitionierte Ziele
gesetzt um eine nachhaltige
Rohstoffversorgung sicherzustellen sowie
die heimischen Rohstoffabbau zu
erleichtern und ökologisch auszurichten
das hat seine Richtigkeit und
Notwendigkeit zum Zeitpunkt der
Verhandlung gehabt und ist heute immer
noch aktuell und auf vor dem Hintergrund
des Gesagten umso wichtiger will aber
vom Kollegen Roloff die Wortwahl
aufgreifen nämlich hat von Siedler von
Catan gesprochen bei diesem Brettspiel
gibt es auch eine entwicklungskarte und
ich finde die sollten wir jetzt ziehen
es gibt und es wird immer notwendiger
auch immer mehr neue Materialien Werk
und Rohstoffe die wir benötigen hier
müssen wir viel viel mehr im
Innovationen und in die Entwicklungen in
neuer Patente investieren da ist der
Staat gefördert und ebenso lassen Sie
mich das noch erwähnen müssen wir genau
auf das Potenzial heimischer Rohstoffe
schauen wir sehen dass die Vorkommen die
im Oberrheingraben zwischen Basel und
Frankfurt entdeckt worden sind 20
Prozent unseres Bedarfs nämlich was
Lithium betrifft decken können und
Glaube liebe Kolleginnen da müssen wir
noch mal genauer hinschauen wir sind in
einer schwierigen wirtschaftlichen Lage
in unserem Land wir müssen alles dafür
tun dass unsere heimische Wirtschaft
insbesondere natürlich die Industrie und
den mittelständischen Betriebe bestehen
können dafür tun wir alles mögliche in
dieser Koalition wir handeln um genau
das zu erreichen vielen Dank
so damit ist die Aussprache geschlossen
interfraktionell wird Überweisung der
Vorlagen auf den Drucksachen 40/42 und
40 65 an die in der Tagesordnung
aufgeführten Ausschüsse vorgeschlagen
herzlichen Dank keine weiteren
Vorschläge dann ist das so beschlossen
wir kommen jetzt nochmal zurück zu den
Tagesordnungspunkten 26c und a so und
bei diesen Abstimmungen die jetzt
anstehen geht ist um die Reaktivierung
des
Stabilisierungsfonds die Abgeordneten
hatten heute morgen ja schon über die
Ausnahme der Schuldenbremse abgestimmt
namentlich also praktisch die technische
Voraussetzung dafür geschaffen diesen
Fond zu reaktivieren bzw 200 Milliarden
Euro aufzunehmen und jetzt geht es darum
ob dieser Fond der ja ursprünglich zur
corona-pandemie eingerichtet worden war
dass der reaktiv wird
das sind die Koalitionsfraktionen wer
stimmt dagegen
das sind die cdu/csu wer enthält sich
das sind AFD und Linke damit ist der
gesetzentwurfung in zweiter Beratung
angenommen dritte Beratung und
Schlussabstimmung wer zustimmen möge
sich bitte erheben
vielen Dank die Gegenstimmen danke sehr
die Enthaltungen
besten Dank damit ist der Gesetzentwurf
in dritter Beratung angenommen mit dem
gleichen Stimmverhältnis wie vorher wir
kommen jetzt zur Abstimmung über den
Entschließungsantrag der Fraktion der
cdu/csu auf Drucksache 41 könnt ihr
danke 41 33
die Fraktion der cdu/csu hat namentliche
Abstimmungen verlangt und die Abstimmung
erfolgt in der westlobby sie haben zur
Abgabe ihrer Stimme nach Eröffnung der
Abstimmung 20 Minuten Zeit die
Schriftführerin und Schriftführer haben
soweit ich weiß
ihre Plätze schon eingenommen damit
eröffne ich die namentliche Abstimmung
über den Entschließungsantrag und die
Urnen werden geschlossen um 12 Uhr
und natürlich geben wir Ihnen das Ende
der namentlichen Abstimmung vorab auch
noch einmal bekannt
ich rufe jetzt auf den
Tagesordnungspunkt 28 hier geht es um
die Beratung der Beschlussempfehlung des
Auswärtigen Ausschusses zum Antrag der
Bundesregierung mit dem Titel
Fortsetzung des Einsatzes bewaffneter
deutscher Streitkräfte Stabilisierung
sichern wieder erstarken des is
verhindern
Versöhnung im Irak fördern so und das
ist ja hier Usus dass die
Bundeswehreinsätze für ein Jahr
verlängert werden so möchte auch die
Bundesregierung diesen Einsatz bis zum
31 Oktober 2023 verlängern sie möchte
weiterhin bis zu 500 Soldaten einsetzen
können das sind viel mehr als momentan
vor Ort derzeit sind rund 150 Männer und
Frauen in Jordanien und dann noch mal 80
weitere im Irak im Einsatz aber
natürlich möchte dort die
Bundesregierung eine gewisse
Flexibilität haben um auf mögliche
Änderungen der Situation zu reagieren
worum geht es geht darum im Irak zu
stabilisieren und auch die terrormiliz
islamischer Staat am Wiedererstarken zu
hindern zwar ist
genau ich wollte jetzt noch weiteres
erzählen aber das muss ich gar nicht
denn das wird die erste Rednerin tun
Sarah Nanni von Bündnis 90 den Grünen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine
Damen und Herren sehr geehrte Vertreter
der werbeauftragten die Präsidentin hat
es gerade vorgelesen wir beraten heute
über den Einsatz bewaffneter deutscher
Streitkräfte Stabilisierung sichern
wieder erstarken ist die erst verhindern
Versöhnung im Irak fördern oder wie wir
es nennen das irakmandat dabei ist das
viel zu kurz gegriffen rund 280
Soldatinnen sind in sechs Standorten in
vier Ländern in Einsatz die Bundeswehr
leistet ihren Beitrag im Rahmen der
internationalen Einsätze nato-mischen
Irak und der anti-soperation in Haren
resolve Schwerpunkt des deutschen
Anteils ist die Beratung der Führung der
irakischen Streit und Sicherheitskräfte
auf strategischer Ebene mit dem Ziel
eben jene zu befähigen
und sie sind es die dafür sorgen dass
der is nicht wieder Fuß fassen kann im
Irak
der Einsatz findet auch im Kontext des
zivilen Engagement von VN und EU statt
die mit der United Nations assistant
Mission Irak und der EU assistance
Mission Irak vertreten sind die
sicherheitspolitische und die
innenpolitische Lage ist mehr als
kompliziert das sagt auch der
überprüfungsbericht der Bundesregierung
der nun erstmals im Parlament vorgelegt
wurde dort heißt es ich zitiere auch
wenn is aktuell keine akute strategische
Bedrohung für Irak darstellt ist die
Terrororganisation weder besiegt noch
nachhaltig eingedämmt seit dem Angriff
der USA und seiner Verbündeten in 2003
für uns in Deutschland und Europa das
markanteste Datum der jüngeren
Geschichte des Irak musste das Land sich
enorm Herausforderungen stellen die
größte bleibt es Erstarken des is in
Irak und Syrien
das Undenkbare wurde Realität die Gruppe
islamischer Staat rief im Sommer 2014
das sogenannte Kalifat aus schätzungen
gehen davon aus dass zum Zeitpunkt der
größten raumkontrolle bis zu 12
Millionen Menschen in Irak und Syrien
unter seiner Herrschaft lebten und
leideten in diesem Territorium wurde
gefoltert gemordet Menschen wurden
drangsaliert ein brutales Regime
durchgesetzt insbesondere gegenüber
Minderheiten wie den jesid:innen kannte
der is keine Gnade das sogenannte
Kalifat wurde zum Sehnsuchtsort von
Dschihadisten weltweit
propagandistisch hoch professionell
rekrutierte die Gruppe islamischer Staat
neues Kanonenfutter für seine
zerstörerischen Pläne auch tausende
europäische auch deutsche diadistinnen
reisten an um für das sogenannte Kalifat
zu kämpfen es bleibt auch im Rückblick
Wahnsinn
gut dass das vorbei ist
was nicht vorbei ist sind Anschläge und
Angriffe durch die Gruppe islamischer
Staat und andere Milizen auch die
innenpolitische Lage ist mehr als
herausfordernd in etwa zeitgleich zu
unserer Bundestagswahl wurden in Irak
letztes Jahr Wahlen abgehalten die
Regierungsbildung dauert nun fast ein
Jahr später weiterhin an erst in der
letzten Woche wurde der Präsident Abdul
Latte Rachid durch das Parlament gewählt
er hat nun mohammi mit der Bildung eines
Kabinetts beauftragt als du Dani steht
vor einer Mammutaufgabe in einer
ethnisch pluralen wenig geübten
Demokratie ein Kabinett
zusammenzustellen dass die Gesellschaft
Irak bestmöglich abbildet und
professionell miteinander und für das
Land arbeiten kann an diesem Wochenende
soll das Kabinett vorgestellt werden ich
wünsche viel Erfolg gut dass es endlich
vorangeht
wenn wir deutsche Soldaten in einen
Einsatz schicken dann ist das und die
Formulierung unserer Mandate tragen auch
dazu bei wenn wir ehrlich sind immer mit
sehr hohen Erwartungen an Erfolge
verbunden fast so als wären sie wären
wir es in Deutschland gewohnt dass wenn
der Staat sich was vornimmt dass immer
ohne Probleme und Rückschläge auch
gelingt und es ist auch richtig
ambitioniert zu sein es ist richtig zu
hinterfragen welchen Beitrag wir leisten
es ist richtig genau zu überlegen bevor
wir unsere gut ausgebildeten Soldatinnen
in ein potenziell für Sie gefährliches
Mandat entsenden mein Eindruck ist die
Bundesregierung tut genau das
Deutschland hat einen guten Ruf sowohl
bei der Zentralregierung in Irak als
auch in Erbil und es ist auch ein Teil
unserer globalen Verantwortung dass wir
diesen guten Ruf zum Vorteil Iraks zum
Vorteil der Region und zum Vorteil
Europas nutzen wir hier im Parlament
beschließen dass Mandat die Regierung
setzt es um und an erster Stelle sind es
die Soldatinnen der Bundeswehr die dies
mit hohem persönlichen Einsatz und einer
hohen Professionalität jeden Tag tun
ihnen gilt unser besonderen unser
besonderer Dank insbesondere in diesen
für Irak sehr herausfordernden Zeiten
liebe Kolleginnen ich bitte Sie auch im
Namen meiner Fraktion heute um
Zustimmung für dieses Mandat
Sarah Nani war das von Bündnis 90 den
Grünen in der Fraktion ist sie
Sprecherin für Sicherheit Frieden und
Abrüstung und für die Unionsfraktion
spricht nun Johann davidpool
CSU-Fraktion wird im Antrag zustimmen
das fällt uns leicht weil wir dieses
Mandat immer befürwortet haben es ist
richtig den Kampf gegen
is-terroristen fortzusetzen es ist
richtig dafür zu sorgen für Stabilität
im Irak zu sorgen flüchtlingsursachen zu
bekämpfen Deutschland hat hier eine
wichtige Rolle und die cdu/csu-fraktion
steht hinter diesem Mandat
sie sehen wir nehmen Verantwortung wahr
dass dies neuerdings auch die Grünen tun
Frau Kollegin Nanni das haben sie
überzeugen dargelegt aber das hätten sie
all die vergangenen Jahre auch schon
machen können also schon auffällig dass
sie jetzt mit einmal zu der Erkenntnis
kommen wie wichtig dieses Mandat ist das
ist in den vergangenen Jahren verloren
gegangen das war das war schon immer
Frau Kollegin Brucker wichtig gegen
Terroristen zu kämpfen und vor allen
Dingen jesidenen zu schützen und das
will ich an der Stelle schon mal sagen
in dieser Region hat der Kampf für
Frauenrechte und der Schutz von Frauen
eine hohe Bedeutung und wer sich für
feministische Außenpolitik einsetzt der
muss sich für die Frauen im Irak
Einsetzen der muss sich für jesidenten
Einsetzen der muss sich übrigens auch
für Iranerinnen einsetzen und da sehen
wir von ihnen überhaupt nicht große
Worte hier ersetzen keine Taten dort
vor Ort dass man dazu Gebiet bleibt
gleich wir werden zwar dafür gewesen die
Luftraum von Syrien einzubeziehen die
Fähigkeiten bleiben erhalten
Luftbetankung bodengestützte Luftraum
Überwachung Teilnahme an FX Flügen aber
auch die Ausbildung von stabsaufgaben
innerhalb des nato-verbundes die
sozialdemokratische Fraktion hat in der
letzten Legislaturperiode hier große
Probleme dass im natorahmen zu tun schön
auch dass dieser Lerneffekt gelungen ist
dass die Sozialdemokraten jetzt auch die
NATO wieder mehr wertschätzen und auch
sagen dass das eine gute Aufgabe der
NATO ist in dieser Region aktiv zu
werden also ich muss sagen der
staatspolitische Bildungsprozess in den
regierungskoalitionsfraktionen
insbesondere bei Grünen und SPD hat
Erfolge gezeitigt Kollege Lechte die FDP
war ja schon immer dafür woran es fehlt
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen und das
möchte ich ausdrücklich bemängeln
ist irgendeine Strategie dieser
Bundesregierung für diese Region wissen
sie der Einsätze sind wichtig der
Bundeswehr sie sind ein notwendiges
Mittel sie sind das letzte Mittel aber
man kann nicht erst den Einsatz machen
und dann mal über eine Strategie für die
Region nachdenken man braucht erst eine
Strategie für den Namen und Mittleren
Osten und dann kann der Einsatz ein
Element davon sein und das ist genauso
in der Sahelzone sie haben für keine der
Konfliktregionen am Rande Europas die
uns bedrohen irgendeine außenpolitische
Strategie und die muss vorgelegt werden
was wir sehen sind
Einzelreisen da reist der
Wirtschaftsminister nach Katar findet
das großartig sich dort zu treffen
Menschenrechte Schutz von Arbeitnehmern
und Arbeitnehmern spielen an der Stelle
mit einmal nicht mehr so eine große
Rolle Abschluss übrigens gleich null
kein Kubikmeter LNG wird von dort hier
ankommen der reißt der Bundeskanzler
nach Saudi-Arabien grundsätzlich richtig
Ergebnis die OPEC drosselt ihre
Liefermenge schadet uns eher bringt
große Probleme für die beiden
Administrationen nutzt nur Putin man
sieht sie haben Einzelaktionen die alle
nicht durchdacht sind und es fehlt jede
durchdachte Strategie für den Namen und
Mittleren Osten und das ist doch die
Region aus der nach wie vor die meisten
Flüchtlinge auch in unsere Richtung
kommen und das ist einzufordern und da
muss ich Ihnen wirklich sagen
da ist ihnen das vorgemacht worden die
Bundeskanzlerin Angela Merkel hatte mit
der libyenkonferenz mit dem
eu-türkei-abkommen mit dem e3+3-format
viele Dinge in die Welt gesetzt die es
würdig wären fortgesetzt zu werden und
da bleibt diese Bundesregierung nach wie
vor gefordert wir stimmen heute zu aber
unsere Erwartung ist dass sie auch ein
strategischen Einsatz für diese wichtige
Region endlich formulieren darüber
würden wir dann gerne auch mit Ihnen
diskutieren und das unterstützen
herzlichen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit
Johann Wade Pool hat hier schon die
Zustimmung der innen Union angekündigt
zur Verlängerung des Bundeswehreinsatzes
im Irak das dürfte den nächsten
rednerfreunde Schmied aus dem
politischer Sprecher der SPD-Fraktion
Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren ich rede gerne über die
durchdachte Strategie der
Bundesregierung die hinter diesem Mandat
steht wir wissen dass der Irak eine
unverändert hohe Herausforderung hat was
die Sicherheitslage anbelangt und die
damit verbundenen Einschränkungen einer
stabilen wirtschaftlichen und
politischen Entwicklung deshalb sind wir
der Auffassung dass gerade weil der Irak
ein potenzieller Stabilitätsanker im
Nahen Osten sein kann wir die Mission